Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist,
dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zu Ausgabe 64 unserer Gesprächsreihe über Wissenschaft und wissenschaftliche Fragestellungen.
Und genau mit solchen wollen wir uns heute nochmal genauer auseinandersetzen,
und zwar den Fragen der Ethik und noch ein wenig konkreter, den Fragen der Ethik rund um medizinische Fragen und die medizinische Forschung.
Und dazu bin ich nach Tübingen gefahren, an die Universität Tübingen, ins Institut für Ethik und Geschichte der Medizin.
Und begrüße meinen Gesprächspartner, nämlich Robert Ranisch, schönen guten Tag.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Herr Ranisch, wir sind hier an einem schönen Hang gelegen, mit schönem Blick über Tübingen, sehr lauschig hier.
Auf jeden Fall ein schönes Gebäude.
Das ist aber nur so eine Außenstelle, kann man sagen?
Das ist keine Außenstelle, es ist nur ein Teil unseres Instituts.
Wir sind die Ethik und Geschichte der Medizin und Sie sind hier gerade in der Ethik.
Ah, ich bin gerade in der Ethik selber drin?
Genau, in der Ethik selber drin sozusagen.
Wobei wir auch nicht die einzige Ethik in Tübingen sind.
Okay, aber das ist Teil der medizinischen Fakultät?
Genau, Teil der medizinischen Fakultät und an das Universitätsklinikum in Tübingen angeschlossen.
Das heißt was?
Das heißt, dass wir von der Institution erst mal einmal der Universität zugehörig sind,
wir haben aber auch enge Verknüpfung an das Klinikum, an die ethische Beratung am Klinikum
und sitzen damit sozusagen zwischen diesen beiden Institutionen.
Das heißt, man hat dann so einen anderen Praxisbezug auch?
Man hat einen ganz konkreten Praxisbezug, nämlich dahingehend, dass wir nicht nur Forschung betreiben und Lehre für die Medizinerausbildung,
sondern dass wir beispielsweise auch in Form des Ethikkomitees am Universitätsklinikum Ethikberatung anbieten.
Und das ist eine ganz handfeste praktische Tätigkeit, die wir gemeinsam mit Ärzten, mit pflegerischem Personal, mit Patienten durchführen, in ethischen Entscheidungssituationen in der Klinik.
Bevor wir da vielleicht drauf einsteigen, würde ich ganz gerne mal Ihren Lebensweg nochmal ein bisschen abklopfen.
Wie sind Sie denn auf diese Weg, auf diese Pfad gekommen?
Ich bin ganz klassisch über Umwege auf diesen Pfad gekommen.
Welche denn?
Was daran liegt, dass es für Medizinethiker eigentlich keine klassischen universitären Ausbildungswege gibt.
Ich habe tatsächlich vor etwas mehr als 15, beinahe 20 Jahren, mein Studium begonnen,
damals noch mit der festen Absicht, dass ich gerne freier Künstler werden möchte.
Und habe mich in Jena, Weimar am Bauhaus versucht einzuschreiben.
Habe mir dort ein Atelier gemietet, meine Bewerbungsmappe vorbereitet und habe eine Ausschreibung gesehen,
dass ein neugegründetes Institut für angewandte Ethik eine CI brauchte.
Also die brauchten ein Logo, sie brauchten Briefköpfe und ich dachte mir,
das wäre ein schöner Zuverdienst, habe damals das Logo für dieses Ethikinstitut entworfen und bin so auf Umwegen zur Hilfskraft des Instituts geworden.
Zuerst für Computer-IT, dann später für Konferenzplakate, Poster und so weiter und ich merkte,
hey das ist gar nicht so unspannend, was die dort machen.
Und das waren ethische Fragen in der Medizin, aber auch ethische Fragen der Technologie, in der Wirtschaft, das war eine sehr sehr schöne Mischung.
Dieser Studiengang lief damals recht neu an und ich musste den dann irgendwie kombinieren
und nach einigen Semesters mendelte sich dann ein Philosophiestudium heraus,
was ich in Jena begonnen habe, dann in England abgeschlossen habe.
Und bin dann über die Philosophie sozusagen wieder zurück zur Ethik, zur angewandten Ethik, gekommen
und jetzt mittlerweile seit sieben Jahren hier in Tübingen.
Okay, das ist ein sehr unerwarteter Verlauf der Lebensplanung.
Auf jeden Fall, damit hätte ich auch nicht gerechnet.
Ist noch ein bisschen was vom Künstlertum übrig geblieben?
Mitunter Webseitengestaltung ist noch übrig geblieben vom Künstlertum.
So eher die sehr angewandte Ecke.
Jetzt frage ich mich, seit wann ist denn Ethik innerhalb des Medizinwesens auch ein eigenes Ding?
Also war das schon immer so, dass man solche Fragen auch explizit erforscht und behandelt hat
oder ist das eher einen Entwicklung der Neuzeit?
Ich glaube tatsächlich, sowohl als auch.
Also wenn wir in die Geschichte der Medizin hineinschauen, das ist jetzt so klassisches Wissen, was ich meinen Studierenden mitgeben würde in den Vorlesungen,
dann fangen wir irgendwann an bei Hippokrates und dem Eid des Hippokrates und da sind in vorchristlicher Zeit schon eine Art von Standesethos fixiert worden,
wie Ärzte zu handeln haben.
Das Ganze hat natürlich nicht mehr so viel zu tun mit dem, was heute Medizinethik betreibt,
aber in der Anlage war es sozusagen da, seitdem es die Ärztezunft gibt.
Die moderne Medizinethik dagegen, die ist vielleicht 40-50 Jahre alt und hat sich insbesondere in den Vereinigten Staaten um die Mitte des letzten Jahrhunderts konstituiert,
Ausgehend von, man muss sagen, ziemlich verbrecherischen Fehlschlägen mit Humanexperimenten.
Ein Knotenpunkt in der Geschichte der Medizinethik sind die sogenannten Experimente Tuskegee,
damals hat man ohne Wissen der Probanden diese mit Syphilis-Erregern infiziert,
um zu schauen, okay wie entwickelt sich da eigentlich die Erkrankung?
Das Ganze wurde dann erst recht spät bekannt, dass man das über mehrere Jahrzehnte gemacht hat
und das führte zur Institutionalisierung von einer Gruppe, die sich zum ersten Mal überlegte,
naja, wenn wir solche Humanexperimente machen, was brauchen wir dann eigentlich für Standards der Aufklärung, der Zustimmung, des Verständnisses?
Und das ist eine der Geburtsstunden der modernen Medizinethik.
Eine andere …
Aber 50 Jahre her.
Ich meine, da reden wir von den 60/70er Jahren.
Genau, 60/70er Jahren.
In den späten 60er Jahren haben sich die ersten Institute für Medizinethik gegründet, in Deutschland etwa ab den 80er Jahren.
Aber hatten wir nicht hier schon zu Zeiten des zweiten Weltkriegs eine ganz handfeste ethische Krise?
Ich meine, so wie das Hitler-Regime mit entsprechenden medizinischen Experimenten umgegangen ist
und Euthanasie betrieben hat, hätte das nicht im Prinzip auch schon direkt nach dem Krieg eine entsprechende ethische Diskussion hervorrufen müssen?
Hat es die gegeben oder ist die erst mal unterdrückt gewesen?
Ganz genau, das wäre der zweite Knotenpunkt in der Geschichte, den ich gerade erwähnen wollte,
dass wir auch aus der deutschen und europäischen Perspektive die Aufarbeitung der Verbrechen des Nationalsozialismus
und gerade der Ärzteschaft, die ja nicht nur beteiligt waren, sondern die auch eine menschenverachtende Ideologie häufig mitgetragen haben.
Sei es in Form von Humanexperimenten mit der sogenannten Eugenik, also der vermeintlichen Verbesserung der arischen Rasse,
über die Euthanasie-Programme, die bekannt sind, die zu tausenden Todesopfern geführt haben.
Die Aufarbeitung dieser Verbrechen kann auch als eine Stunde der Medizinethik gezählt werden,
wobei es von der Aufarbeitung bis zur Institutionalisierung noch einige Jahre gedauert hat.
1980, das ist ja dann schon 30-35 Jahre, eine ganze Menge.
Genau, das ist eine ganze Menge.
Es gab natürlich davor auch schon eine Reihe von Personen, sei es aus der Medizin, aus der Theologie heraus,
die versucht haben, einzelne Standards, einzelne ethische Normen und Werte hineinzubringen in die ärztliche Praxis.
Es gibt international verschiedene Dokumente, die die Ärzteschaft verpflichten auf ein besonderes Ethos.
Das gab es im Anschluss an den zweiten Weltkrieg, aber die Institutionalisierung der Medizinethik hat tatsächlich etwas gedauert.
Und wie hat sich das dann institutionalisiert?
Das hat sich auf verschiedenen Wegen institutionalisiert.
Nämlich zum einen eher aus den Geisteswissenschaften heraus, seitens der Theologie und der Philosophie,
dass ist dort zunehmend in der ethischen Forschung ein ganz handfestes Interesse an praktischen Fragen gab.
Dass man also sagte, wir wollen Ethik nicht mehr nur aus dem Lehnstuhl heraus beantworten,
sondern wir wollen in Anbetracht von technologischen Entwicklungen,
und das war dann eben nicht nur die Medizin, die zunehmend zu einer Art Apparatemedizin wurde,
sondern beispielsweise auch Atomkraft oder Fragen der Mobilität, der Medien,
dass die ein Reflexionsbedarf hervorgerufen haben.
Und den haben Philosophen, Theologen versucht zu füllen.
Das war die eine Schiene, über die sich die Medizinethik institutionalisierte.
Die zweite Schiene ist eher aus der Praxis heraus, nämlich aus der klinischen Forschung, klinischen Anwendung.
Dass Mediziner, die ja ein breitgestreutes Interesse hatten auch an der reflexiven Arbeit, über die die Tätigkeit ihrer eigenen Zunft anfing, ethische Fragen prominenter zu stellen.
Zu versuchen, die auch sozusagen auf den Klinikflur mit hineinzubringen.
Und das war zugleich auch begleitet von ganz sich sehr stark ändernden Paradigmen im Arzt-Patienten-Verhältnis.
Dass der Arzt zunehmend aus dieser Rolle von Halbgott in weiß wegrückt zu jemandem,
der einem auf Augenhöhe und eher informierend vor dem Hintergrund eines Ideals der Autonomie des Patienten bei den therapeutischen Eingriffen,
bei Heilseingriffen zur Unterstützung da ist für den Patienten, aber eben nicht über den Patienten sozusagen bestimmen darf.
Und das ist dann die zweite Schiene, also eher aus der Klinik heraus gedacht.
Die zur Herausbildung der Medizinethik beitrug.
Das heißt, es ist auch eine Geschichte und eine Frage des Selbstverständnisses der Mediziner selbst?
Auf jeden Fall.
Und ich denke, dieses Selbstverständnis kann man auch sehr gut im letzten Jahrhundert sehen, wie es sich gewandelt hat.
Eben wie gerade angesprochen, von dieser Person, die paternalistisch im ganz klassischen Sinne des Wortes,
nämlich als der gütige Vater, der besser weiß, was gut für den Patienten ist, als der Patient selbst, über ihn wacht.
Hin zu einer Art Begegnung auf Augenhöhe zwischen Arzt und Patient.
Und das hat dann natürlich auch dazu geführt, dass man bei Themen der Ausbildung von Medizinern sehr früh versucht anzusetzen
und die Medizinethik im Curriculum zu verankern.
Was mittlerweile seit etwa 15 Jahren in Deutschland auch verpflichtend ist in jeder Medizinausbildung, dass es einen Ethikteil gibt.
Also in Form von Kursen oder?
In Form von Kursen, in Form von Vorlesungen, in Form von Workshops, genau.
Und das ist auch Teil der Aufgabe unseres Instituts, dass wir eben diese Ethikausbildung gewährleisten für unsere Medizinstudenten hier in Tübingen.
Also nur in Tübingen oder generelle Leitlinien auch zu entwickeln, wie es in anderen Studiengängen angewendet werden soll?
Also geht das über Tübingen hinaus?
Das kann über Tübingen hinausgehen, wenn wir etwa im Rahmen von Forschungsprojekten uns damit beschäftigen,
wie kann man Ethikausbildung implementieren an verschiedenen Universitäten.
Um Ihnen ein Beispiel zu geben, ich habe zuvor an dem Ethikzentrum hier in Tübingen gearbeitet,
das ist nochmal eine eigene Institution.
Die haben sich sehr stark mit der Frage beschäftigt, wie kann in die Ausbildung von Führungspersönlichkeiten in der Wirtschaft,
wie können dort ethische Themen stärker eingestreut werden, im Sinne einer Organisationsethik.
Also wie können Personen, aber auch Strukturen, so gestaltet werden, dass Organisationen verantwortungsvoll umgehen.
Zum einen nach innen mit ihren Mitarbeitern, aber eben auch nach außen, in der Außenkommunikation mit ihren möglichen Kunden und so fort.
Und dahingehend hat das Ganze eben nicht nur eine Beschränkung auf die Tübinger Studentenschaft,
aber eben gerade hier am Institut sind sie für uns das Zentrum der Ausbildung.
Also es sind auch Empfehlungen jetzt für den Betrieb von Kliniken?
Beispielsweise von Kliniken, aber auch von größeren Gesellschaften,
vor allen Dingen auch Firmen in der freien Wirtschaft, mit denen wir häufig zusammengearbeitet haben im Rahmen dieses gerade benannten Projektes.
Und das ist tatsächlich sehr vielfältig.
Und ich denke auch, dass in den letzten Jahren da eine starke Zunahme an Reflexionsbedarf auch sichtbar wird seitens von verschiedenen Organisationsformen
und das beschränkt sich gar nicht nur auf die Klinik, sondern auf private Akteure, die merken,
ja wir haben es zunehmend mit sich verändernden Bedingungen auf dem Markt zu tun,
mit anderen Anforderungen seitens unserer Kundschaft, seitens unseres Personals, dass wir eher wertereflektiert auch unsere Unternehmen betreiben wollen.
Und da ist die Ethik mittlerweile auch, denke ich, sehr sehr gut aufgestellt als eine Unterstützung für solche Organisationsformen tätig zu sein.
Betrifft das auch die Pharmakologie, also die Entwicklung von Arzneimitteln?
Ich meine, das ist ja auch so eine ethische Debatte, dieses, machen wir nur Medikamente für Leute, die sich das auch leisten können?
Oder forschen wir in Bereiche hinein, wo wir möglichst vielen Leuten helfen können?
Das ist ja im Prinzip auch so eine ethische Grundfrage.
Also ganz grundsätzlich muss man sagen, dass, wenn Sie in Deutschland oder überall in der Welt neue Arzneimittel entwickeln wollen, es da ein sehr engmaschiges Netz gibt von Regularien,
die Sie erfüllen müssen, bis das Produkt irgendwann auf den Markt kommt.
Und ein ganz wesentlicher Teil dabei ist auch das Votum der sogenannten Ethikkommission.
Die Ethikkommission sitzt bei uns auch hier mit im Haus, die Ethikkommission des Universitätsklinikums.
Das heißt, sobald Sie anfangen, einen Forschung zu betreiben, sei es mit einem neuen Wirkstoff oder sei es mit Probanden in welcher Form auch immer,
muss die Ethikkommission darauf schauen, ob das Ganze grundsätzlich ethischen Richtlinien entspricht.
Ganz offensichtlich wäre zum Beispiel die Frage, sind die Probanden, die sich dazu bereit erklären, entsprechende neue Wirkstoffe an sich zu testen,
sind sie entsprechend aufgeklärt darüber.
Eine andere Frage ist aber auch, können wir überhaupt davon ausgehen, dass dieses Medikament, was jetzt erprobt wird, dass es einen zusätzlichen Nutzen bringt?
Wenn sich im Vorfeld schon zeigen sollte, dass dieses Medikament keinen Vorteil hätte gegenüber anderen Arzneimitteln, die wir auf dem Markt finden,
könnten wir bereits deshalb sagen, sollte eine Forschung ausgeschlossen werden, weil wir brauchen keine nutzlosen neuen Medikamente auf dem Markt.
Hat denn diese Kommission, reden wir jetzt von einer konkreten Kommission oder von einem Konzept einer Kommission?
Wir reden von einer konkreten Kommission.
Also wir reden von einem Pool von Menschen, die in dieser Ethikkommission sitzen, das ist ein multidisziplinär besetztes Team
und die begutachten die Anträge, die eingereicht werden und jeder Forschungsversuch hin Tübingen muss durch diese Ethikkommission durch,
wenn er mit Probanden zu tun hat.
Okay, also das ist ein verpflichtender Teil sozusagen des Systems?
Das ist ein verpflichtender Teil, genau.
Und davon gibt es deutschlandweit eine ganze Reihe von Ethikkommissionen.
Beispielsweise sitzt in Stuttgart noch die Ethikkommission der Landesärztekammer, die sind dann eben für Forschungsvorhaben außerhalb der Universität Tübingen zum Beispiel zuständig.
Wenn ein privates Pharmaunternehmen sagt, wir wollen hier wir Forschung an einer Klink in Baden-Württemberg betreiben,
dann geht das Ganze in der Regel durch diese Ethikkommission, die in Stuttgart sitzt.
Also da gibt es mittlerweile ein ziemlich breites Netz von entsprechenden Kommissionen,
die darüber achten, dass ethische Standards eingehalten werden in der Entwicklung.
Aber wenn jetzt Forschung nur innerhalb des Unternehmens vorgenommen wird, ist diese Ethikkommission erst mal aus dem Spiel?
Das kommt darauf an, also wenn Sie Forschung innerhalb des Unternehmens betreiben und dabei auch Probanden rekrutieren müssten,
bräuchten Sie in der Regel auch ein Votum durch eine Ethikkommission.
Ah okay, also es ist schon auch rechtlich bindend?
Das Ganze hat eine rechtliche Bindung in gewisser Weise, ja.
Das heißt, man kann sagen, das ist jetzt nicht nur so eine theoretische Geschichte, dass sich ein paar kluge Leute mit Ethik auseinandersetzen,
sondern das, was innerhalb der ethischen Forschung und der wissenschaftlichen Arbeit entwickelt wird,
sind auch die konkreten Maßstäbe, die dann unter anderem in solchen Kommissionen zum Ausdruck kommen
und die dann eben auch eine klare bindende, verpflichtende Wertvorgabe für Unternehmen und Universitäten darstellt?
Das kann es mitunter sein, aber ich denke, es ist noch mehr.
Weil jenseits der Möglichkeit, dass wir durch ganz klassische Gesetze oder Richtlinien versuchen zu normieren,
dann gibt es ja auch einen ganz realen Reflexionsbedarf, dass wir häufig mit Akteuren zu tun haben,
sei es bei uns in der Klinik, die sagen, es geht uns gar nicht darum, dass wir jetzt keine Gesetze brechen wollen,
sondern wir haben tatsächlich eine Frage, was wäre jetzt hier aus der ethischen Sicht das richtige zu tun?
Und dafür sind wir sozusagen auch eine Reflexionsinstanz, dass wir versuchen dann sehr häufig in multidisziplinären Teams zusammenzukommen
und in Entscheidungsprozessen da zu unterstützen an der Stelle.
Und das tatsächlich macht für mich auch den Reiz der Medizinethik oder generell der angewandten Ethik aus,
dass sie eben nicht nur wie die klassische Philosophie versucht, in ihrem Elfenbeinturm zu bleiben und nach letzten Wahrheiten zu suchen,
sondern wirklich in die Welt hinausgeht und dort gemeinsam mit verschiedenen Akteuren Problemlösungen hervorzubringen.
Ist denn das jetzt eigentlich nur von einer rein wissenschaftlichen Perspektive her definiert
oder wird da auch die Gesellschaft in Form von Kirche und anderen moralischen Instanzen noch mit beteiligt?
Im besten Fall sollte sie das.
Also die Ethik ist ja keine Moralwissenschaft in dem Sinne, dass wir mit dem Zeigefinger da stehen und sagen, das ist jetzt gut und das ist richtig und das sollte getan werden.
In der Regel geht es darum, dass wir mit den Mitteln der analytischen Philosophie in der Ethik eher Analyseraster bereitstellen,
dass wir sehr sensibel sind für die Verwendung von Begriffen, Probleme zu identifizieren,
aber wie dann letztendlich entscheiden wird, das maßt sich die Ethik meist nicht an.
Und dafür versucht sie sozusagen Reflexionsräume zu schaffen und die sollten möglichst breit besetzt werden.
Und jetzt kommt es auf den Gegenstandsbereich an.
Wenn wir von einer Herausforderung sprechen, die sich jetzt im Kleinen, also beispielsweise einer Patientenentscheidung sich darauf bezieht,
kann es genügen, dass wir sagen, wir versuchen zusammenzukommen in einem multidisziplinären Team mit vielleicht 5-10 Leuten,
das sind dann Seelsorger, Pfleger, gegebenenfalls Angehörige, behandelnde Ärzte und meist ein Ethiker beteiligt
und versuchen dann, für diesen Fall eine Lösung auszuhandeln.
Wenn es um größere gesellschaftlicher Herausforderungen geht, sei es, was ist momentan sehr breit diskutiert,
autonomes Fahren und wie sollen Algorithmen gestaltet werden für solche autonomen Systeme,
dann muss auf jeden Fall die Gesellschaft möglichst breit einbezogen sein und das heißt dann eben natürlich auch die Kirchen,
aber eben auch sehr viele mehr darüber hinaus, Interessenverbände, sozusagen die relevanten Stakeholder in diesem Moment.
Jetzt sind solche Fragen ja auch in der Politik auch auf Bundestagsebene ein wichtiges Thema.
Es hat sich ja irgendwann dieser deutsche Ethikrat herausgebildet, hatte, glaube ich, sogar noch einen Vorgänger?
Der Nationale Ethikrat.
Der Nationale Ethikrat, danach war er nicht mehr national, danach war er nur noch deutsch.
Genau.
Okay. Was ist das für ein Gremium?
Der Ethikrat ist ein politikberatendes Gremium, was der Bundesregierung und dem Bundestag sozusagen zur Seite steht bei entsprechenden Fragen,
die meist sich aus Biotechnologien und Technologieentwicklung in der Medizin heraus ergeben.
Und dieser Ethikrat setzt sich zusammen auch multidisziplinär, meist mit Fachvertretern aus verschiedenen Wissenschaften,
aber auch Praktikern und aus der Zivilgesellschaft mitunter auch Akteuren.
Und die versuchen in der Regel durch Stellungnahmen, durch Gutachten, durch Empfehlungen politikberatend zu wirken,
zugleich aber auch durch öffentliche Veranstaltungen, der Ethikrat hat einmal im Jahr eine große Jahrestagung,
aber auch viele kleinere Symposien, die sie ausrichten, eine Außenkommunikation zu schaffen für diese ethischen Themen zur Gesellschaft hin.
Und das kann eben Themen betreffen, die so vielfältig sind wie Technologieentwicklung.
Also sei es zu Fragen des autonomen Fahrens, da gibt es mittlerweile auch eine eigene Ethikkommission für diese Fragen, muss man sagen
oder Fragen der Genomeditierung, der Gendiagnostik, der Herausforderungen, die sich durch eine alternde Gesellschaft stellen.
Also das ist ein sehr sehr breites Feld, was da versucht wird, dass man es abdecken möchte.
Und funktioniert das?
Das funktioniert so gut, wie beratende Gremien funktionieren.
Sie haben natürlich die Herausforderungen in einen Raum zusammenbringen, dann haben Sie zwei Meinungen in der Regel.
Das bildet sich auch beim Ethikrat ab, so dass der Ethikrat in aller Regel nicht sagt, wir saßen jetzt ein halbes Jahr zusammen und haben die Antwort gefunden auf das Problem.
In der Regel ist der Ethikrat da differenzierter und hat einzelne Voten zu Themen, die aufgebracht wurden, hat dann auch Sondervoten,
die können mitunter auch ganz widersprüchlich sein.
Das Ganze kann man beklagen, das Ganze kann man aber auch als eine willkommene Vielfalt in Bezug auf diese Fragen, die da behandelt werden, sehen
und letztendlich muss man ja sagen, ich glaube, wir tun uns keinen Gefallen damit, wenn wir eine Art von Ethokratie einführen würden,
wo wir sagen, die Ethiker sollen dann da sitzen und die heiklen Themen der Gesellschaft klären.
Das ist eine Frage, die muss letztendlich durch die Parlamente durch.
Dafür haben wir Volksvertreter legitimiert und diese Legitimation hat erst mal eine Ethikkommission oder ein deutscher Ethikrat nicht.
Und dementsprechend würde ich sagen, erfüllt es die Funktion, die es erfüllen kann,
aber natürlich muss man realistische Erwartungen haben daran, was so ein Rat leisten kann.
Und das ist eben dann in der Regel eine beratende Funktion und auch eine informierende Funktion für die Gesellschaft.
Kommen wir doch mal so ein bisschen auf die konkreteren Themen, mit denen sich jetzt die Ethik zumindest derzeit so beschäftigt.
Großes Ding, klang ja eben auch gerade schon an, sind so die Fragen um die Genetik, Genomeditierung,
ein Feld, was ja auch einen enorm technischen Fortschritt gesehen hat in den letzten 20-30 Jahren, sehe ich das richtig?
Die Genomeditierung eher in den letzten zehn Jahren oder fünf Jahren.
Okay, aber die Gen…, ich weiß nicht, was jetzt der richtige Begriff wäre, wann man einsteigt,
aber dass man sozusagen überhaupt auf Genebene medizinisch arbeitet.
Genau, also es gibt seit, wenn wir allgemein davon sprechen, dass wir Gene, also das Erbgut von Lebewesen, verändern können,
ist die Geschichte mittlerweile recht lang, die reicht bis in die 60er Jahre zurück,
da hat das dann mit Versuchstieren im Labor geklappt, also meist mit Mäusen oder mit Ratten oder auch mit kleineren Organismen.
Da hat man sozusagen den Beweis erbracht, wir können gezielt genetische Veränderungen hervorrufen oder wir können auch gezielt Gene einbringen in Lebewesen.
Was wir in den letzten, ich sagte gerade fünf Jahren, ich glaube, das stimmt so, etwa seit 2012 sehen können,
ist eine rapide Beschleunigung in dem Bereich der Gentechnik und das ausgelöst durch ein neues Werkzeug oder durch neue Werkzeuge,
die zur Anwendung gebracht wurden und die werden meist unter das Schlagwort Genomeditierung oder Genomchirurgie gebracht.
Was ist damit gemeint?
Damit sind neue technische Verfahren angesprochen, die es erlauben, leichter als zuvor die DNA, also das Erbgut von allen Lebewesen, zielgenau zu verändern.
Und damit verbinden sich momentan sehr sehr große Hoffnungen.
Dass man sagt, wir haben bisher meist in recht teuren, kostspieligen Verfahren nur ungenaue Veränderungen hinbekommen
von möglichen Lebewesen oder auch für eine Anwendung in therapeutischen Kontexten, also für Heilversuche, haben wir das bisher nicht sehr zielgenau hinbekommen
und jetzt scheint es, zumindest nach Ansicht der Wissenschaftsgemeinschaft, einen Durchbruch gegeben zu haben.
Und viele reden da auch von Revolution, gerade ausgelöst durch die sogenannte CRISPR/Cas-Technologie.
Das ist ein etwas komplizierter Akronym, was für die bekannteste Genschere steht, mit der man doch allerlei erstaunliches geschafft hat in den letzten fünf Jahren, seitdem sie zur Anwendung gebracht wurde.
Was wurde denn damit geschafft?
Man hat in den ersten Jahren, seitdem diese Genscheren zur Anwendung gebracht wurden, so gut wie in jedem Lebewesen hat man es geschafft, Veränderungen hervorzurufen mit unterschiedlichen Erfolgen.
Das Ganze hat Einfluss auf ganz lebenswirkliche Bereiche.
Zum Beispiel eins der ersten Produkte, von der man überlegt, sie auf den Markt zu bringen, waren Pilze gewesen, die nicht mehr braun werden.
Man hat also einen Eingriff in die Genetik von Pilzen erzielt und die haben dann Produkteigenschaften verändert.
Man hat im Bereich der sogenannten grünen Gentechnik, also der Agrogentechnik, hat man eine ganze Reihe von Pflanzen durch diese Verfahren hervorgebracht, die resistenter sind gegen extreme Wettersituationen,
die ertragreicher sind, die bessere Produkteigenschaften haben, beispielsweise Sojabohnen, die gesättigte Öle produzieren können.
Man hat im Bereich der Nutztierhaltung sogar Versuche unternommen, dass man die Hörner von Kühen sozusagen verschwinden lässt, damit diese für sich selbst und aber auch für die Halter keine Gefahr mehr darstellen.
Und man hat letztendlich auch versucht im Bereich der Humanmedizin diese Genscheren für mögliche therapeutische Zwecke einzusetzen.
Bleiben wir vielleicht doch erst mal bei dieser Agrardimension.
Ich meine, an sich ist genetische Mutation nichts neues.
Genau.
Weil einerseits ist das nunmal der evolutionäre Lauf der Dinge, aber auch eben diese gezielte Weiterentwicklung.
Alles, was wir, glaube ich, heutzutage im Supermarkt so an Gemüse kaufen können, gab es vor 200 Jahren so nicht.
Oder Sie würden es nicht Wiedererkennen.
Wenn ich Ihnen eine Kartoffel zeigen würde von vor 200 Jahren oder eine Möhre, ja.
Weil die kleiner, anders gefärbt, anders ausgeprägt.
Runzliger in der Regel.
Runzliger, krumpliger genau.
Ja.
Vielleicht war die Banane noch nie krumm, wer weiß es so genau.
Genau, das heißt, der Mensch hat ja quasi diese genetische Mutation schon immer bewusst betrieben, aber eben mit relativ einfachen Methoden.
Zunächst einmal einfach durch Selektion.
Man hat halt einfach geschaut, ah hier ist eine Pflanze, die scheint irgendwie besser zu wachsen, die wird irgendwie größer, toller, hat mehr Früchte oder wächst auf einmal in einem Gebiet,
wo noch gar nichts wuchs, offenbar hat die sich in irgendeiner Form angepasst, die nehme ich jetzt mal und versuche, die eben gezielt weiter zu entwickeln.
Das ist ja eigentlich das, wie sich die komplette Landwirtschaft, wie wir sie heute kennen, bis zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt entwickelt hat.
Wann fing denn das an, dass hier die Technologie wirklich das noch weiter vorangetrieben hat, als nur durch die reine Selektion?
Also ich würde Ihnen erst einmal recht geben.
Auf einer Ebene stimmt das, wir waren in gewisser Weise immer Züchter gewesen, seitdem wir angefangen haben, Landwirtschaft zu betreiben,
seitdem wir beispielsweise Tiere domestiziert haben, haben wir es uns zunutze gemacht, dass durch natürlich vorkommende Mutationen,
dass wir zum Beispiel ertragreichere Pflanzen uns produzieren konnten für die Anwendung.
Das Ganze hat dann in den letzten 100 Jahren, natürlich vor dem Hintergrund einer sich industrialisierenden Landwirtschaft hat das allerlei Blüten getragen,
dass man versucht hat, effizientere, effektivere Wege zu finden, um entsprechende Veränderungen zielgenau zu erwirken.
Das Ganze wurde durch klassisches Auskreuzen versucht, das Ganze wurde aber auch beispielsweise durch Bestrahlung von Samen oder von Saatgut versucht.
Bestrahlung wäre jetzt eine sehr ziellose Form, um Mutationen hervorzurufen, aber das gute an Pflanzen ist eben, dass wir relativ schnell sie züchten können, auskreuzen können,
und können sehen, ob sich damit Eigenschaften ändern, die erwünscht sind.
Also Bestrahlung heißt, Radioaktivität?
Durch Röntgenstrahlen, genau.
Und damit können wir mehr oder weniger ziellos Mutationen hervorrufen, nur das wurde das 20. Jahrhundert hindurch vielfach gemacht und das ist ein Standard in der Pflanzenzucht, der angewandt wird.
In der zweiten Hälfte des 20. Jahrhunderts wurden dann zunehmend neue Verfahren entwickelt, von denen sprachen wir vorhin bereits, mit denen sich gezielt etwa fremde Gene einbringen lassen in Pflanzen,
und da gab es damals schon die Diskussion, okay wollen wir da wirklich gezielt auch sozusagen in die Evolution eingreifen, indem wir etwa sagen,
eine Raupe ist resistent gegen diesen oder jenen Umwelteinfluss, jetzt können wir das Gen der Raupe nehmen, das in die Pflanze hineinpacken und die Pflanze wird auch resistent.
Oder das wahrscheinlich bekannteste Beispiel, der sogenannte Golden Rise, also ein Reis, den man mit einem extra Gen ausstattet, damit er Vitamin A produziert
und hat damit andere Produkteigenschaften.
Das waren sogenannte transgene Pflanzen, die dort geschaffen wurden.
Das hat man mit sehr sehr aufwendigen und auch langwierigen Verfahren der Gentechnik gemacht
und was nun eben möglich ist durch die Genomeditierung ist etwas ganz spannendes,
nämlich dass das nicht nur wesentlich schneller und einfacher geht als bisher,
sondern auch, dass man sozusagen die Evolution selbst beschleunigen kann,
in einer Form, dass Mutationen gezielt ausgelöst werden, die auch auf natürlichem Wege hätte entstehen können.
Sie sind es nicht, aber sie hätten auch auf natürlichem Wege entstehen können, das heißt, dass wir bei manchen dieser Pflanzen,
die heute genetisch verändert werden, im Produkt gar nicht mehr sagen können, wurde die verändert oder nicht
oder hat die sich einfach natürlich so entwickelt?
Was heißt denn, hätte natürlich passieren können?
Ich meine, alle Pflanzen sind ja permanent einer Strahlung ausgesetzt.
Selbst wenn man jetzt nicht nochmal intensiv mit Röntgen oder sonstigen radioaktiven Quellen drauf strahlt,
ist ja die kosmische Strahlung ohnehin da und das, was irgendwie unsere tägliche Mutation auslöst.
Also inwiefern ist das jetzt ein natürlicherer Vorgang als das andere, was ja eigentlich auch schon ein natürlicher Vorgang ist?
Das ist eben genau die Frage.
Sie haben natürlich recht, jede Pflanze, jeder Hektar Weizen der mutiert vor sich hin erst einmal.
Auch auf eine ganz natürliche Art und Weise, was auch immer jetzt natürlich hier heißt in diesem Zusammenhang.
Also durch natürliche Einflüsse.
Genau, durch natürliche Einflüsse.
Das kann man erst einmal so feststellen.
Was das besondere nun ist an diesen neuen Verfahren, dass man quasi die Mechanismen, die ohnehin vorhanden sind in Pflanzen,
dass man die ausnutzen kann, um bestimmte Mutationen zu erzielen und weil dann eben kein fremdes Gen eingebracht wurde,
wie bei früheren Verfahren, kann man im Produkt nicht mehr sagen, ob die nun gezielt verändert wurden
oder ob die durch sehr viel Zeit und Aufwand zum Beispiel einfach so gezüchtet wurden, dass sie diese oder jene Eigenschaften haben diese Pflanzen.
Die dann vermeintlich genetisch verändert sind oder nicht.
Was für Mechanismen sind das?
Das ist eben der Mechanismus, der mit CRISPR/Cas beschrieben wird.
Das ist eben eine von diesen möglichen Genscheren, die es momentan gibt.
Das ist ein Mechanismus, den hat man schon vor einigen Jahren entdeckt, konnte ihn aber noch nicht so richtig verstehen.
Was hat man da gesehen?
Man sah, dass, wenn Bakterien durch Viren angegriffen werden, Bakterien irgendwann eine Art von natürlichem Abwehrmechanismus gegen diese Viren entwickeln können.
Und das machen die, indem die sich merken oder indem die sich Teile der DNA der Viren in ihrer eigenen DNA speichern, um dann dem Virus,
wenn er noch einmal angreifen sollte, wiederzuerkennen und unschädlich zu machen.
Also so ein Immunsystem.
Genau sozusagen eine Art Immunsystem, die manche Bakterien haben.
Und diese Immunsystem konnte man nun nutzen, um was ähnliches zu basteln, mit dem man, wie ein Bakterium das auch kann, DNA schneidet.
Dass man sagt, wir haben eine Art von Ortungssystem entwickelt.
Das kann zielgenau in die Zelle hinein geworfen werden, findet dann den entsprechenden Bereich auf der DNA,
kann den schneiden und dann wird sich das in der Regel wieder miteinander verbinden und wir haben damit zum Beispiel ein Gen ausgeschaltet oder ein Gen rausgeschnitten.
Oder wir können auch ein neues Gen einsetzen auf diese Art und Weise.
Und das ist so ganz grundlegend und etwas vereinfacht beschrieben der Ansatz dieser CRISPR/Cas-Technologie und den kann man sich bei eben allen Lebewesen zunutze machen.
Das heißt, diese Schere, ist ja ein schwieriges Wort, ist nicht eine mechanische Schere, die jetzt den Genstrang an der einen Stelle einfach abschneidet
und dann setzt man da was anderes ein und dann war es das?
Sondern man verwendet quasi eine – jetzt weiß ich nicht, ob ich den richtigen Begriff finde – aber es klingt für mich ja schon fast mechanisch,
der quasi auf dem Genstrang abläuft, aber durch die Pflanze oder durch das Objekt selbst durchgeführt wird.
Jain, also Sie müsse in aller Regel zwei Komponenten haben.
Zwei Komponenten reichen, um das zu erklären.
Sie brauchen zum einen sozusagen den Spürhund, der die richtige Stelle auf dem Genom findet.
Und wenn der gefunden ist, muss der noch eine Schere dabei haben, das ist dann zum Beispiel dieses Cas9 bei CRISPR/Cas9
und diese Schere kann dann an der entsprechenden Stelle, die der Spürhund gefunden hat, kann er dann schneiden.
Wer löst das aus?
Das macht das Cas9, dass geschnitten wird.
Und das Ganze ist kein physischer Prozess, das Ganze ist ein molekularbiologischer Prozess, der abläuft.
Der an sich aber ein zelleigener Mechanismus ist von manchen Bakterien, der sich da zunutze gemacht wird.
Also genau derselbe Mechanismus, der auch sonst zum Einsatz kommen würde in der Pflanze, nur dass man ihn forciert?
Ich denke, nicht ganz.
Also es soll nicht der Eindruck entstehen, dass, wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir verändern eine Pflanze, dass die das ohnehin auch selbst hätte machen können,
es geht eher darum, dass die Werkzeuge, die man dazu nutzt, dass diese Werkzeuge quasi aus der Natur entnommen wurden
und damit Veränderungen hervorgerufen werden bei der Pflanze, bei der nicht notwendigerweise wie früher etwas artfremdes eingefügt wird.
Früher hat man sozusagen versucht, das kennt man vielleicht von diesen GloFishs, das sind diese kleinen Fische, die kann man im Internet kaufen,
in Deutschland darf man das wahrscheinlich nicht, aber in Amerika, die können leuchten im Dunkeln.
Was hat man da gemacht?
Da hat man sich ein Gen von einer Qualle, die fluoresziert genommen und hat das in diese Fische eingebracht.
Wenn ich jetzt diese Fische mir anschaue und wenn ich die sequenziere, dann kann ich sehen,
ah okay, da ist jetzt ein Abschnitt von diesem fluoreszierenden Quallengen drin, deshalb sind das transgene Fische.
So ist das nicht notwendigerweise bei der CRISPR-Technologie, wie die sozusagen mit dem, was jetzt der Fisch in dem Beispiel oder der Reis in einem anderen Beispiel,
was der hat, mit dem kann es arbeiten und kann dann sagen, okay ich schalte jetzt hier Gen A, B und C aus und habe damit eine neue Eigenschaft hervorgerufen,
die der Reis dann ausprägt.
Das heißt aber eben auch, dass hier nur noch das Verfahren Gentechnologie ist, aber das Produkt – das ist strittig der Punkt –
das Produkt kann selbst nicht mehr als gentechnisch verändert identifiziert werden, weil ich eben nicht, wie zum Beispiel GloFish, dann diesen Genabschnitt drin entdecken kann,
von dem ich mit Sicherheit weiß, der kommt von etwas artfremdem.
Warum kann man sich da so sicher sein?
Weil die …
Also was macht dieses transgene Element so anders?
Also wenn ich da neu drauf schaue und feststellen will, kommt das von woanders her, woran erkenne ich das, dass das von woanders herkommt?
Das Ganze ist keine Notwendigkeit, dass das das einzige ist, was sie machen können mit diesen neuen Genscheren,
aber das ist eben eine Möglichkeit, dass sie quasi einfach einen Knockout von einem Gen hervorrufen, dass dieses Gen deaktiviert wird.
Und wenn das geschieht, werden sie einfach nach einer Sequenzierung nichts mehr finden können, was darauf hindeutet, da wurde jetzt gerade Gentechnik betrieben.
Und das im Übrigen ist auch der Hintergrund des langanhaltenden Streits, ob diese veränderten Organismen,
wenn wir jetzt in der Pflanzenzucht bleiben, sagen wir, ein Weizen, ob der als genetisch veränderter, genetisch modifizierter Mechanismus, also GMO, deklariert werden muss oder nicht
und da hat sich jetzt der Europäische Gerichtshof vor einigen Monaten dafür ausgesprochen, ja, es wird als ein solches GMO muss es deklariert werden,
weil eben das Verfahren ein gentechnisches ist.
Beispielsweise haben sich aber die amerikanischen Regulierungsbehörden, also das Departement for Agriculture hat sich dagegen ausgesprochen
und hat gesagt, nein, wenn das Produkt tatsächlich „naturidentisch“ ist, wie es auch durch eine konventionelle Züchtungsmethode hätte hergestellt werden können,
dann muss es nicht entsprechend deklariert werden als ein GMO.
Das heißt, hier gibt es noch Unterschiede zwischen USA und Europa?
Genau, hier finden Sie Unterschiede zwischen Europa und den USA und da werden Sie auch global momentan noch keinen Konsens finden.
Weil die Debatte ist ja auch sehr stark geprägt von einem politischen Streit, nämlich die Frage, wie gehen wir um mit der allgemeinen Ablehnung,
die Sie beispielsweise in Deutschland auch finden, gegenüber Gentechnologie.
Viele Verbraucher sagen, sie wollen keine genetisch veränderten Lebensmittel haben
und dieses Label von, es ist genetisch verändert oder es ist künstlich, ist in gewisser Weise auch ein politischer Kampfbegriff geworden,
aber auch ein Aspekt des Verbraucherschutzes.
Und ich denke, hier kann man legitimerweise auch sagen, wenn Verbraucher das nicht möchten, ist das in Ordnung.
Auf einer anderen Ebene müssen wir aber fragen, passiert da wirklich grundsätzlich etwas ganz verschiedenes im Vergleich zu diesen Mutationen,
die durch Röntgenstrahlung beispielsweise ausgelöst werden können, die momentan nicht reguliert sind als genetisch veränderte Organismen.
Das heißt, Sie können nachher zwei verschiedene Pflanzen haben, die eine ist mit CRISPR verändert, bei der anderen wurde das Saatgut über Röntgenstrahlung entsprechend verändert.
Sie können im Produkt keinen Unterschied mehr finden, aber das eine wird als genetisch veränderter Organismus gewertet und das andere wird nicht als genetisch veränderter Organismus gewertet.
Aber es ist beides im Ergebnis von derselben Qualität?
Genau, jetzt in dem Szenario kann man sich denken, dass sie identisch sind auf der genetischen Ebene,
aber sie haben eben einen unterschiedlichen Weg hinter sich gehabt, wie sie da hingekommen sind.
Aber es wäre tatsächlich dasselbe im Sinne von wirklich dasselbe?
Wir sind gerade in einem Gedankenexperiment.
Ja, in diesem Sinne könnten Sie sich vorstellen, dass auf der genetischen Ebene Sie keine Unterschiede mehr finden zwischen beiden.
Sie müssten dann aber unterschiedlich deklariert werden bzw. die einen würden in Deutschland gar nicht auf den Markt kommen,
weil es gibt hier keinen Absatzmarkt für genetisch veränderte Lebensmittel.
Ja. Das heißt, das ist hier wirklich jetzt auch ein schwieriger Diskussionsbereich, der einerseits von einem technischen Verständnis her erst mal auch ausgeht,
das heißt, je nachdem wie gut man das versteht, kommt man vielleicht zu anderen Bewertungen und natürlich vielleicht auch auf so eine übergeordnete Sache.
Ist sozusagen wie etwas herbeigeführt wurde, also so lässt man den Zufall walten, etwas anderes,
als wenn man eben gezielt irgendwo hingeht und damit ja auch eine gewisse Motivation mit einbringt,
etwas anderes, selbst wenn es im Ergebnis identisch ist.
Genau, und ich denke, eins der … und das ist ja ein ethisches Thema, eins der grundlegenden Fragen, die sich damit verbinden,
sind unsere Intuitionen, die wir haben, in Bezug auf Natürlichkeit.
Was wir damit meinen, wenn wir sagen, etwas ist kulturell geformt oder ist künstlich oder etwas ist natürlich.
Und ich denke, da sind sehr viele auch Verbraucher in Deutschland davon umgetrieben,
dass wir da eine klare Opposition haben, entweder ist das Ganze, wie das der Bauer schon immer gemacht hat und dann kriegen wir die Kartoffel, wie sie schon immer war
oder es ist eben künstlich verändert.
Wenn man dann jemand damit konfrontiert und sagt, okay wir haben eigentlich auch schon vor 2000-3000 Jahren in gewisser Weise Gentechnik betrieben,
wenn wir Bier gebraut haben.
Ist es auf der einen Ebene banal zu sagen, das ist Gentechnik, auf der anderen Ebene ist es aber genau das.
Und da merkt man, dass wir als Menschen da eben immer in dieser Zwitterposition sind, dass wir selbst von Natur aus kulturelle Artefakte hervorbringen.
Wir überformen und dementsprechend ist das zumindest auf der philosophischen Ebene sehr schwierig,
da einen verlässlichen Wegweiser zu finden zwischen diese beiden Kategorien.
Man müsste fairerweise sagen, sehr sehr vieles ist eigentlich so ein Zwitter aus natürlich und künstlich.
In der Philosophie wird mitunter von Biofakten gesprochen, also nicht biologisch, auch kein Artefakt, sondern ein Biofakt,
das wir da zwar eingegriffen haben und auch modifiziert haben, aber da eben auch noch sozusagen Lebenskräfte mit am Werk sind.
Und das ist vielleicht auch eine adäquatere Kategorie, um Fragen der sogenannten Gentechnologie zu verhandeln
und wir müssen uns dann letztendlich als Gesellschaft die Frage stellen, wollen wir das Ganze oder nicht?
Und das muss auch die Gesellschaft entscheiden, denke ich, aber möglichst aufgeklärt.
Und da fehlt es mir in den letzten Diskussionen auch um die Genomeditierung häufig auch an einem offenen Dialog
über das, was es eigentlich heißt zu sagen, wir greifen hier gezielt ein und was sind eigentlich die Alternativen dazu?
Und jedesmal, wenn Sie Verbrauchern, oder nicht jedesmal, aber sehr häufig, wenn Sie mit Verbrauchern reden,
gibt es da einfach noch ein sehr sehr romantisiertes Bild von, was heißt Landwirtschaft eigentlich im 21. Jahrhundert?
Und das stimmt natürlich auf ganzer Linie nicht.
Die landwirtschaftlichen Betriebe sind hoch durchindustrialisierte Betriebe,
angefangen vom Saatgut bis zum Traktor bis hin zu computergestützten Systemen, die weit eingesetzt werden
und verschiedenen Pestiziden oder Pflanzenmitteln.
Da stimmt was nicht mit der breiten Wahrnehmung.
Und da würde ich mir wünschen, wenn wir weiter den offenen Diskurs suchen über derartige Fragen.
Ja, da sind wir ja gerade mittendrin.
Ich frage mich jetzt gerade, was eigentlich so der Grund dafür ist, dass insbesondere in Deutschland dieser Widerstand so ausgeprägt ist
und warum er sich unter anderem in dieser Gendebatte auch so stark festmacht.
Da kann man ja einerseits sagen, naja diese ganzen Heilsversprechen, die haben ja auch schon in den 70er Jahren gehört
und dann haben wir irgendwie tonnenweise Gift auf unsere Welt gegossen und es gab halt Dioxin-Skandale, DDT, was nicht alles,
also es ist schon so viel mit, nee seid mal ganz ruhig Leute, das ist schon alles total super, ihr werdet sehen, so und alles wird gut
und Zukunft ist und fliegende Autos und dann war das Ergebnis halt, naja sorry, leider alles vergiftet, tut uns leid.
War ja keine Absicht.
Ja.
Dass da sozusagen auch so eine gewisse Skepsis sich daraus entwickelt hat und damit natürlich dann auch so ein aktiver Zweifel an der nächsten Welle,
wenn wieder alle ankommen, nee nee, ist total natürlich und so.
Wissenschaftler haben herausgefunden, dass …,
dass einfach da dieser Glaube an der Stelle so einfach gar nicht mehr da ist.
Also hat man wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen etwas verspielt an Vertrauen vorher, was jetzt erst mal auch wieder zurückgewonnen werden muss.
Die Frage ist, ist das so und kann das überhaupt noch gelingen, dieses Vertrauen wieder herzustellen?
Also ich würde Ihrer Diagnose da zustimmen.
Ich denke, dass gerade diese Hochtechnologien, wie genetische Veränderung, sogenannte ???,
dass sich mit den seit sie aufkam in den 70er Jahren immer wieder diese Hoffnungen, Ängste zugleich verbunden haben
und das sehr sehr stark polarisierend.
Und das rangiert dann von, das wird uns alle retten, zu, es wird uns alle töten.
Und ich glaube, dass das dem Diskurs nicht gut getan hat, dass wir da weiter in diesen sehr sehr schwarz-weiß-Kategorien festhängen
von den Heilsversprechen der Zukunft der Ernährung unserer Bevölkerung.
Also nicht der deutschen Bevölkerung, sondern der globalen Bevölkerung.
Hin zu, jetzt haben wir wirklich sehr sehr risikoreiche Technologien.
Und ich denke, dass da eben auch wichtig ist zu sehen, es geht da nicht um solche ausgeprägten Revolutionen in der Landwirtschaft,
die von heute auf morgen alle umkrempeln können, sondern es geht um Fragen von Ertragssteigerung von 10-20%.
Und wir können aber momentan auch gar nicht genau absehen, ob das Ganze jetzt nicht nur ökologisch, sondern auch ökonomisch und sozial, nachhaltig ist.
Das Ganze sehen wir auch in Bezug auf die Anwendung am Menschen.
Wir haben seit den späten 1980er Jahren, frühen 1990er Jahren haben wir die ersten Gentherapien,
also Therapien mit der Genetik, wo Gene eingeschleust wurden damals noch in den menschlichen Körper.
Und seitdem gibt es die Versprechen ja, sie könnten unser Leben verlängern, sie könnten Krebs heilen und so weiter.
Man muss sagen, wir haben jetzt beinahe 30 Jahre später so gut wie keine Gentherapien auf dem Markt.
Das Ganze waren Entwicklungen, die über viele Jahre laufen, das ist naturgemäß so,
von denen aber sehr sehr wenige wirklich zu einem Ertrag geführt haben.
Und da müssen wir, glaube ich, aufpassen, dass wir uns selbst nicht in der Illusion wiegen,
dass wir jetzt die Lösung für alles gefunden hätten durch diese neuen Verfahren der Genomeditierung.
Und das kann auch eine Mahnung sein, beispielsweise an unsere Sprache zu denken.
Ich habe vorhin wie selbstverständlich von Genomchirurgie oder genetischen Skalpellen gesprochen,
und da schwingt natürlich schon ein Vertrauensvorschuss mit, eine Präzision von diesen Werkzeugen,
von denen gar nicht klar ist, ob sie überhaupt gegeben ist.
Da gibt es sehr viel im Detail zu entdecken und da ist, glaube ich, wichtig, das im Hinterkopf zu behalten,
dass wir da einen etwas nüchterneren Diskurs führen über diese Entwicklungen.
Aber auch in beide Richtungen.
Weil auf der anderen Seite ist ja die CRISPR/Cas-Technologie nicht nur für ihre Technologie als solche jetzt in der Diskussion,
weil das irgendwie neu ist, sondern weil man auch sieht, es erzielt auch wirklich sehr interessante neue Ergebnisse,
die bis vor kurzum noch überhaupt so nicht vorstellbar waren.
Genau, es erzielt sehr interessante Ergebnisse und das kann im ganz wörtlichen Sinne als eine disruptive Technologie gelten.
Also CRISPR hat in den letzten Jahren aus den Laboren die bisherigen Verfahren vertrieben.
Und ich höre das auch in Diskussionen mit Postdoktoranden, weil sie sagen,
ja, ich habe damals noch meine Doktorarbeit mit diesem oder jenem Verfahren gemacht, das könnte man heute im Rahmen einer Bachelorarbeit schaffen,
weil das einfach so viel schneller und kostengünstiger geht mit diesen neuen Genscheren.
Aber man muss eben sagen, wir sind da wirklich noch sehr sehr am Anfang.
Das, was wir momentan betreiben, ist in alle Regel Grundlagenforschung.
Und auch oder gerade die Anwendung am Menschen, da laufen die ersten klinischen Studien erst an.
Das, was wir bisher sagen können, ist, im Labor sieht das Ganze vielversprechend aus,
wie das dann aber mal in die Anwendung gebracht werden kann, ist nochmal eine ganz andere Frage.
Weil da haben wir wie gesagt auch schon die Erfahrung mit vorherigen Entwicklungen,
dass sie uns in Sackgassen geführt haben oder dass sie eben nicht so gut funktioniert haben in der Praxis,
wie man sich das im Labor vorher versprochen hat.
Schauen wir doch vielleicht mal so auf die früheren Versprechen und Dinge, die sich eigentlich auch in einem ähnlichen
und auch in einem ethischen Bereich bewegen.
Da ist zum Beispiel die künstliche Befruchtung zu nennen.
Ja, der Mensch aus dem Reagenzglas.
Ich weiß nicht, womit fing das an, mit dem Schaf Dolly, glaube ich?
Nein, nicht ganz das Schaf.
Nein?
Sondern das war das erste Klonschaf.
Das erste Klonschaf richtig.
Das war geklont und das war 1997, aber bereits 20 Jahre vorher, 1978, wurde der erste Mensch geboren,
der außerhalb des Mutterleibs gezeugt wurde.
Das war eine Britin, die Frau Louise Brown, die jetzt gerade ihren 40. Geburtstag gefeiert hat dieser Tage.
Ach ja genau.
Und das war der erste sogenannte Retortenmensch oder das Retortenbaby, wie es damals noch genannt wurde.
Ja, Retortenbaby, das war das, was ich im Kopf hatte.
Genau. Und das ist tatsächlich ein sehr schönes Beispiel auch für Technologiegewöhnung,
weil man sagen muss, was damals passierte, grenzte mitunter an eine Massenhysterie,
dass, als bekannt wurde oder sich abzeichnete, da wird das erste Kind geboren, was außerhalb des Mutterleibs gezeugt wurde,
der Untergang des Abendlandes von manchen hervorgesehen wurde.
Mittlerweile können wir 40 Jahre später sagen, das Ganze ist komplett normalisiert.
Keiner findet heute mehr Anstoß daran, dass außerhalb des weiblichen Körpers es zu einer Zeugung kommt,
mit Ausnahme vielleicht der katholischen Kirche, die das bisher als unsittlich ablehnt.
Wir haben momentan weltweit etwa acht Millionen Kinder, die durch eine sogenannte IVF, also die Invitrofertilisation, die künstliche Befruchtung, gezeugt wurden.
Das deutsche Register dafür spricht von, ein Kind pro Schulklasse im Durchschnitt, das ist vielleicht etwas hoch gerechnet, aber so in die Richtung gehen die Zahlen.
Und da würde ich davon sprechen, da haben wir eine recht rapide Technologiegewöhnung erlebt.
Von eben einer sehr kruden Ablehnung in einzelnen Teilen der Gesellschaft, hin zu, wunderbar, das Ganze kann für Paare,
die sich nicht auf natürlichem Wege einen Kinderwunsch erfüllen können, kann es eben die Familienplanung ermöglichen.
Was ja auch einhergeht mit einem Trend zu einer steigenden Unfruchtbarkeit.
Genau, also die Zahl von … ich weiß nicht, ob ich von einem Trend sprechen würde, dass Menschen unfruchtbar werden,
aber ganz klassisch die Familienplanung verschiebt sich halt einfach biografisch nach hinten, eher in die 30er und nicht in die 20er
und damit haben Sie ja naturgemäß eine schlechtere oder eine geringere Wahrscheinlichkeit für eine erfolgreiche Familienplanung.
Das Ganze hat vermutlich jetzt nicht primär biologische Gründe, sondern eher soziale Gründe,
dass sich da in der Gesellschaft was geändert hat.
Mit den Arbeitsstrukturen, die wir momentan vorfinden.
Aber es ist natürlich ein ganz reales Problem.
Man spricht von etwa eins von fünf Paaren, die nicht problemlos nach einem Jahr ein Kind zeugen können
und die landen dann eben in der Regel bei Ärzten und das kann eine ganze Reihe von Ursachen haben.
Und für viele kann dann eben diese Invitrofertilisation, diese IVF, kann dann eben den Weg zum Wunschkind bedeuten.
So dass auch Paare gegebenenfalls, die sonst keine Kinder zeugen können, sich ihren Familienwunsch erfüllen.
Aber ich dachte jetzt zu wissen von Studien, die auch nachweisen, dass so die Zahl der Spermien im Schnitt zurückgeht bei den Männern.
Also dass sozusagen solche Aspekte schon auch mit reinkommen.
Ja. Ich kenne diese Studien auch.
Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher, ob diese Studien oder ob diese Einsichten jetzt sehr viel erklären können in Bezug auf die Rate an Unfruchtbarkeit innerhalb der Gesellschaft.
Okay, also es ist auch ein kultureller Wandel, der da mit reinspielt
und der dann wiederum auch die Akzeptanz befördert, weil es mehr Leute betrifft und es dann normaler wird.
Natürlich und dazu zählt auch in letzter Zeit das verbreitete Phänomen, dass natürlich viele Frauen gerade auch in ihren späten 20ern,
Anfang ihrer 30er Jahre gerade mitten in ihrer Karriereplanung mitunter sind,
das Studium ist abgeschlossen, immer mehr Leute studieren, dann wird der Berufseinstieg nach hinten verschoben.
Dann sind die ersten zwei Jahre meist die Zeit, in der man sich in seinem Beruf sortiert, dann stehen neue Herausforderungen an
und vielleicht wird dann die Familienplanung immer weiter nach hinten geschoben.
Ich sehe das in meinem eigenen Freundeskreis, das ist eine sehr verbreitete Herausforderung.
Und dann ist die Frage, okay jetzt so Mitte 30 müsste man dann langsam beginnen mit der Familienplanung,
ansonsten werden die Chancen statistisch schlechter.
Und da in diese Kerbe schlagen dann natürlich auch manche Unternehmen rein, die sagen,
ja, wir bezahlen Frauen dann gegebenenfalls auch, dass sie ihre Eizellen einfrieren lassen,
um erst einmal Karriere zu machen und dann die Familienplanung hinten anzustellen.
Aber dafür eben noch Eizellen zur Verfügung zu haben.
Ich halte das Ganze für einen sehr problematischen Trend, weil die Erfolgsquoten extrem schlecht sind
bei so einem social egg freezing, wie das heißt.
Aber ich glaube, das ist symptomatisch für ein Phänomen, was sich eher durch verändernde Sozialstrukturen oder Berufsstrukturen erklärt werden kann.
Jetzt aber auch genau in diesem Bereich gab es ja jüngst ein paar Studien, von denen ich nicht genau weiß, wie sehr sie zur Beunruhigung jetzt schon aufrufen sollten,
weil wie es eben so ist mit Studien, die kommen und gehen manchmal auch wieder,
aber dass gerade die Kinder, die durch künstliche Befruchtung erzeugt wurden,
unter Umständen eine höhere Wahrscheinlichkeit für Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen nach sich ziehen.
Wie muss man mit solchen Meldungen umgehen?
Ich wäre zunächst einmal vorsichtig mit solchen Einzelstudien.
Was wir tatsächlich haben, ist, ein Problem in Bezug auf die Langzeitüberwachung von Nachkommen,
die nach so einer künstlichen Befruchtung auf die Welt kamen.
Und wir müssen es aber auch einordnen in den zeitlichen Kontext.
Ich meine, wir haben jetzt diese künstliche Befruchtung, die IVF, seit 40 Jahren,
die Zahl war natürlich in den ersten Jahrzehnten nicht so hoch wie es heute ist.
Sagen wir mal, vermutlich sind die meisten nach IVF gezeugten Kinder irgendwann in den 90ern geboren,
das heißt, die werden jetzt langsam junge Erwachsene.
Es gibt einfach sehr wenige Studien darüber, ob das Ganze eine Langzeitwirkung haben könnte,
dass da außerhalb des Mutterleibs gezeugt wurde, sei es durch epigenetische Faktoren oder sei es durch verschiedene Kulturmedien,
die eingesetzt werden, um Eizelle und Samenzelle miteinander zu verschmelzen oder zu einer Befruchtung zu führen.
Was wir momentan sagen können ist, es gibt da diese wirkliche Lücke,
gerade auch auf andere Verfahren der assistierten Reproduktion, wo man nicht versuchte, gezielt Langzeitüberwachung einzuführen,
was aber natürlich auch verständlich ist, weil welches Kind oder welche Person möchte schon über die 20-30 Jahre seines Lebens ständig als quasi Proband in so einem Humanversuch seine genetischen Daten rausgeben
oder seine Gesundheitsdaten rausgeben.
Da verliert einfach jeder auch das Interesse daran und da muss man auch vor einem forschungsethischen Standard sagen,
jeder darf nein sagen bei solchen Experimenten.
Auch wenn ich gezeugt wurde als Kind in so einer IVF, kann ich natürlich später sagen, ich möchte jetzt nicht mehr meine Informationen mit Ihnen teilen.
Und ich glaube, das ist auf der einen Seite ein ganz reales Phänomen, auf der anderen Seite muss man aber auch sagen,
ist gerade die Technik in Bezug auf Reproduktion sehr sehr schlecht reguliert.
Es hat kürzlich ein Humangenetiker in einem Journal ein Editorial geschrieben, in dem er meinte,
naja die Kulturmedien, die wir nutzen in unseren Laboren für die künstliche Befruchtung,
die sind schlechter deklariert als jede Packung Erdnussbutter im Supermarkt.
Was ist ein Kulturmedium?
Das Kulturmedium ist quasi der Nährboden in dem Reagenzglas oder in der Petrischale, auf der sich dann die Eizelle entwickelt.
Und das ist schlechter reguliert als Erdnussbutter?
Schlechter deklariert.
Deklariert.
Das heißt, wenn die das kaufen von dem Großhändler, kriegen sie da mitunter unterschiedliche Qualität vielleicht,
kriegen sie verschiedene Nährböden, können das aber gar nicht wirklich wissenschaftlich erforschen,
ob das Ganze vielleicht ein Outcome, also eine Folge, hat auf die Entwicklung des Embryos, auf die Entwicklung der späteren Person.
Und da gab es jetzt nun eine erste Studie, die wohl gezeigt hat, dass das Geburtsgewicht der Kinder, der Neugeborenen,
korreliert mit den unterschiedlichen Kulturmedien.
Ich glaube, die Bottomline ist, da gibt es noch viel zu entdecken und da hat man bisher eher weggeschaut
ob der Faszination, ah das Ganze funktioniert.
Und da werden sich zukünftig Forscher bemühen müssen zu schauen, was hat das eigentlich für Wirkungen?
Und da gibt es momentan eine Reihe von Überlegungen, dass sich einzelne Krankheitsbilder vielleicht häufen könnten bei solchen Nachkommen aus einer assistierten Reproduktion,
aber ich denke, da gibt es momentan keinen Grund zur Panik.
Also das …
Zumindest nicht generell, sondern es kann halt sein, dass eben einfach solche Rahmenaspekte, wie zum Beispiel dieses Kulturmedium, das verwendete,
noch viel größeren Einfluss darauf haben als die Tatsache, dass es an sich außerhalb des Körpers gezeugt wurde?
Ich glaube, selbst das kann man momentan nicht mit Sicherheit sagen.
Es gibt verschiedene Theorien.
Sehr viele Forscher gehen davon aus, dass die epigenetischen Faktoren außerhalb … oder dadurch dass es außerhalb des Mutterleibs gezeugt wurde,
dass die einen Einfluss darauf haben, dass sich der Embryo anders entwickeln könnte.
Was heißt epigenetisch konkret?
Epigenetik das sind Regulationsmechanismen, die zur Aktivierung und Deaktivierung von Genen führen können.
Das ist ein recht neuer Zweig in der Forschung, der entdeckt wurde, dass man heraus bekam,
naja, obwohl wir jetzt die Genetiker recht gut verstanden haben, verstehen wir immer noch nicht so richtig, wie sich genetisch eigentlich was ausprägt
und dann merkte man sozusagen, es gibt da noch eine zweite Ebene, eine epigenetische Ebene,
dass Gene an- und ausgeschaltet werden können, und das kann durch Umwelteinflüsse zum Beispiel eben ein Kulturmedium erfolgen
und da gibt es verschiedene Theorien, dass, dadurch dass es außerhalb des Mutterleibs eben zur Zeugung kommt,
da andere epigenetische Mechanismen wirken könnten.
Aber wie gesagt, da sind wir momentan noch sehr in den Anfängen zu verstehen, ob es da vielleicht bedenkliche Konsequenzen gibt.
Was man sagen kann, ist, nach 40 Jahren, die IVF ist in der Regel gilt sie als sicher.
Es gibt die Abstriche von Kohortenstudien, wo man sagt, okay da gibt es eine erhöhte Rate an Fehlbildungen in manchen Verfahren der assistierten Reproduktion,
bei anderen nicht, aber wie gesagt, sie gilt generell erst einmal als sicher.
Was vielleicht bedenklicher ist, sind mögliche Nebenwirkungen, die das Ganze auf die Schwangere haben kann,
weil man natürlich für eine assistierte Reproduktion an die Eizellen der potenziell Schwangeren herankommen muss.
Dafür wird in der Regel hormonell stimuliert und da wird mitunter davon gesprochen,
dass das Ganze mit Risiken für die Schwangere in Verbindung stehen kann.
Aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Ja, vorher probiert man vielleicht einfach mal Erdnussbutter aus als Kulturmedium, wenn das so gut deklariert ist.
Das heißt, das ist auch ein gutes Beispiel für, wie sich die Dinge dann auch wieder entspannen können,
wo man dann einfach über die Zeit auch einen Ausgleich findet, indem man dem einfach auch ein bisschen Raum lässt.
Genau, also wenn ich gerade davon sprach, dass die assistierte Reproduktion sich mittlerweile vielleicht normalisiert hat
und dass wir sie akzeptieren, auch wenn vielleicht nicht häufig darüber gesprochen, weil gerade Familienplanung das sind sehr sensible Fragen für viele Personen,
kann man doch sagen, dass die Technik sich normalisiert hat,
was vermutlich aber nicht für die Auswahl von Embryonen gilt.
Weil zu sagen, wir befruchten eine Eizelle außerhalb des Mutterleibs und übertragen sie, das ist die eine Sache.
Zu sagen, wir schauen danach noch, was hat eigentlich dieser Embryo, der noch im Reagenzglas oder in der Petrischale liegt, was hat der für genetische Eigenschaften?
Und selektieren dann anhand von den genetischen Eigenschaften, um beispielsweise Krankheitsfaktoren auszuschließen, das ist die andere Frage.
Und gerade bei dieser Technik der Embryonenselektion, muss man sagen, sind wir gerade in Deutschland noch sehr sehr zögerlich damit, diese auch rechtlich zuzulassen.
Da gab es jetzt vor einigen Jahren eine Veränderung im Embryonenschutzgesetz, dass man einen neuen Paragraphen einführte,
der prinzipiell das Ganze unter sehr strengen Kriterien zulässt.
Insgesamt sind wir damit aber international noch recht konservativ.
Das heißt, nur wirklich im Fall von vermeintlich schweren Erbkrankheiten, von denen gewusst wird, die weitergegeben werden könnten an die Nachkommen,
darf in Deutschland ein Embryo selektiert werden.
Also wenn wir von Embryonenselektion sprechen, was ja wirklich ein sehr technischer Ausdruck ist, reden wir dann im Prinzip von so einer Wunschkind-Debatte auch.
Also man will halt auf der einen Seite entweder bestimmte Eigenschaften haben oder eben bestimmte Krankheiten nicht,
es sei denn, also einerseits, weil man vielleicht generell da eine Para davor hat, dass man sagt irgendwie, ja mein Kind darf nicht behindert sein in irgendeiner Form
oder sollte bestimmte Eigenschaften nicht haben, weil die mir selber nicht gefallen.
Oder eben, ein anderer Punkt noch ein bisschen, it runs in the family.
Wir haben hier ein Krankheitssystem, was in unserer Erblinie immer mal wieder durchgeschlagen ist,
wir würden das gerne ausschließen wollen, weil ist halt doof.
Wie läuft da diese Debatte auch, also wie läuft auch diese ethische Debatte in diesem Punkt?
Weil da gibt es ja kein richtig und falsch in dem Sinne.
Genau, vermutlich gibt es da kein richtig oder falsch, was zumindest für alle Verbindlichkeit beanspruchen kann.
Was wir sehne ist, seit den frühen 90er Jahren gibt es diese Möglichkeiten der Embryonenselektion und in einigen Ländern, wo sie eher lax reguliert wurde,
finden sich Ausprägungen, dass Sie heute zum Beispiel in den USA Fortpflanzungskliniken finden, die selektieren Ihnen auch Embryonen anhand ihrer Augenfarbe.
Das heißt, Sie können ein Angebot dazu buchen für, sagen wir, 500 US-Dollar und dann können Sie nicht nur Krankheiten ausschließen, sondern auch sagen,
okay ich hätte gern auch ein Kind, was blaue Augen hat.
Das sind in der Regel private Kliniken, die sehr sehr wenigen Regularien unterliegen.
Das Ganze hat nicht sehr viel zu tun mit dem, was klinische Realität ist und was in Deutschland besprechen, da geht es wirklich darum,
dass sehr schwere Erbkrankheiten ausgeschlossen werden sollen, die Weitergabe von diesen Erbkrankheiten.
Das betrifft auch häufig Fälle von Paaren, die mitunter schon erkrankte Kinder haben.
Weil meist wissen ja Paare auch gar nicht, dass sie in ihrer genetischen Kombination entsprechende Krankheitsrisiken weitergeben könnten.
Und das wird dann im Einzelfall in Deutschland momentan entschieden, ob das Ganze zulässig ist oder nicht.
In Großbritannien beispielsweise sind momentan etwa 500 genetische Faktoren zugelassen, auf die selektiert werden darf.
Das sind zum großen Teil auch sehr schwere Erbkrankheiten, aber zum Beispiel auch die Veranlagung für Brustkrebs,
dass wir also nur von einem genetischen Risiko sprechen, dass wir sagen können, okay dieses Kind hat eine erhöhte Wahrscheinlichkeit irgendwann mal an Brustkrebs zu erkranken.
Oder auch Krankheiten, wie frühmanifestierendes Alzheimer, wo man sagen würde, da haben wir jetzt ein Krankheitsbild,
was zumindest den Patienten die ersten 30 Jahre ein ganz normales Leben geben würde, bis es dann vermutlich irgendwann mal manifest wird, diese Alzheimer-Erkrankung.
Auch gegen derartige Faktoren darf mitunter in Großbritannien selektiert werden.
Deutschland ist da momentan wie gesagt sehr restriktiv auf der globalen Landkarte, muss man sagen.
Wenn man jetzt die Logik der Genschere auf dieses Thema anwendet, dann könnte man ja auch noch sagen,
okay, ich könnte Embryo selektieren, aber ich könnte ja im Prinzip mir auch das Embryo gleich so zusammenschnippeln, wie ich es gerne hätte.
Also dass man von vornherein sagt, okay da ist jetzt zwar die Anlage für eine Krankheit mit drin, aber die schneiden wir jetzt einfach mal raus und dann nehmen wir halt das.
Ja, tatsächlich kommen eine ganze Reihe von Forschern zu diesem Ergebnis, dass sie sagen, warum sollten wir jetzt eigentlich in Zukunft noch selektieren,
wenn wir denn gezielt eingreifen können?
Und da kommt dann das Szenario auf, dass wir sagen, ja die Genschere, ein CRISPR an Embryonen könnte dann doch vielleicht diese Mutation zielgenau verändern,
so dass das Kind gesund geboren wird.
Das Ganze, muss man sagen, ist momentan noch sehr spekulativ und vermutlich wird es so nicht funktionieren und ich sage Ihnen auch gleich warum.
Vielleicht noch ein Hintergrund, wir haben jetzt erst seit drei Jahren Embryonen genetisch verändert, aber nur in der Grundlagenforschung.
Das heißt, keiner dieser Embryonen wurde bisher in einen Mutterleib übertragen.
Das Ganze begann alles vor drei Jahren 2015 mit einem chinesischen Forschungsteam, was zum ersten Mal diese sogenannte rote Linie der Keimbahntherapie überschritten hat.
Keimbahntherapien sind solche Eingriffe an Embryonen.
Warum spricht man hier von einer roten Linie?
Weil die Veränderungen, die genetisch vorgenommen werden, die sind vererbbar.
Das ist eine ganz eigene Form von Gentherapie, die da erfolgt, dahingehend, dass eben nicht nur das Kind, was sich aus dem Embryo entwickelt,
sondern auch noch die Kindeskinder diese entsprechende Veränderung in sich tragen könnten und damit aber eben auch mögliche Fehlschläge einer solchen Veränderung,
also die Nebenwirkung einer Genomeditierung würden in nachfolgenden Generationen manifest.
Deshalb galten Keimbahntherapien bisher als, viele sprechen von einem Rubikon der Wissenschaft, der nicht überschritten werden darf.
Das ist gebröckelt, diese Mauer sozusagen.
2015 gab es die ersten Versuche.
Das führte dann Ende des Jahres dazu, 2015, dass man sich kurz vor Weihnachten darum verständigte, eine Art freiwilligen Forschungsstopp einzuziehen.
Damals kamen in Washington die US-amerikanischen Wissenschaftsakademien überraschenderweise zusammen mit den chinesischen, auch Vertreter der DFG aus Deutschland waren dabei,
der Royale Society kamen zusammen und haben auf einem großen Symposium versucht, ethische Leitlinien aufzustellen,
wie mit solchen Möglichkeiten der Veränderungen von Embryonen umgegangen werden soll.
Sie kamen dabei zu einem Abschlussdokument und in dem hieß es, momentan darf nicht, sollte nicht weiter geforscht werden.
Bis, Bedingung Nummer 1, wir wissen, dass es sicher ist und Bedingung Nummer 2, sich die Gesellschaft auf Grenzen verständigt hat.
Ganz bewusst wurde hier von der Gesellschaft gesprochen, dass wir quasi einen internationalen Diskurs brauchen,
um auszuhandeln, wollen wir eigentlich genetisch veränderte Menschen haben sozusagen?
Die Geschichte wäre jetzt noch etwas länger und ich will sie gar nicht so im Detail erzählen,
die Pointe war, zeitgleich kam es bereits zu Zulassungsverfahren in Großbritannien, dass man Grundlagenforschung an Embryonen mit CRISPR durchführte.
Es kam in Schweden dazu, dass sie zugelassen wurden, es kam in den Vereinigten Staaten dazu, dass 2017 Embryonen verändert wurden
und in China gab es seitdem auch etwa eine Hand voll Experimente.
Das heißt, dieser vermeintliche Forschungsstopp, den es einmal gab, war überaus ineffektiv, er wurde bereits einige Monate später gerissen.
Es gibt seitdem etwa 10-15 Versuche mit Embryonen.
Was hat man gemacht?
Man hat versucht, schwere Erbkrankheiten auszuschließen, etwa die Sichelzellenanämie oder Betataläsemie???.
Man hat aber auch, und das ist ganz beachtlich, versucht, Mutationen einzubringen in Embryonen und hat so beispielsweise Embryonen erzeugt, die resistent waren gegen das HI-Virus.
Das heißt, wenn die ausgetragen würden, könnten die nicht an Aids erkranken, so die Hoffnung.
Und hat damit quasi nicht nur eine klar therapeutische Zielstellung erforscht, sondern sozusagen eine Art Präventive, eine Art Impfung gegen Aids hat man versucht,
an diesen Embryonen durchzuführen.
Momenten wie gesagt gibt es noch keinen Versuch, das Ganze in die klinische Anwendung zu überführen,
also diese Embryonen in den Mutterleib zu übertragen, weil man eben auch immer wieder Fehlschläge sieht.
Man merkt, diese Genscheren schneiden nicht so genau, wie man sich das erhofft.
Es kommt zu sogenannten Off-Target-Effekten, also außerhalb der Zielstelle wird geschnitten.
Dennoch gibt es nicht wenige, die sagen, das ist nur noch eine Frage der Zeit.
Wir werden vermutlich in den nächsten Jahren irgendwann in den Medien lesen, das erste Kind ist geboren,
was als Ergebnis einer solchen Genomeditierung, einer Keimbahnveränderung gezeugt wurde.
Nun zurück zu der Frage.
Kann das einmal die Präimplantationsdiagnostik, also die Embryonenselektion ersetzen?
Ich denke nein, aus folgendem Grund.
Auch wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass diese Genscheren einmal sehr sehr genau arbeiten könnten,
tun wir gut daran, dass wir kontrollieren, ob sie wirklich so gut und zuverlässig geschnitten haben, wie wir uns das erhoffen,
und dafür brauchen wir wiederum eine genetische Diagnose von dem Embryo.
Und das kann heißen, dass wir den Embryo danach wieder ausselektieren, wenn wir merken, die Genscheren haben nicht gut gearbeitet.
Zugleich sollten wir, bevor wir Genom editieren an einem Embryo, wissen, was der überhaupt für ein Erbgut trägt,
weil vielleicht ist der ja gar nicht betroffen von der entsprechenden Erbkrankheit und dann würden wir ganz sinnlos dort mit diesen Genscheren hineingehen.
Dafür brauchen wir auch wieder eine Gendiagnostik.
Und wenn wir dann merken, ach der Embryo ist ja gar nicht betroffen, dann ist die Frage, warum sollten wir die Genscheren überhaupt noch einsetzen,
weil dann können wir auch die vermeintlich gesunden Embryonen gleich übertragen.
Oder wir merken, er ist betroffen und dann können wir die Genscheren anwenden, aber dann müssen wir wie gesagt im zweiten Schritt noch einmal schauen,
ob sie überhaupt gewirkt haben.
So oder so …
??? sozusagen selektieren.
Genau, in dem wahrscheinlichsten Szenario werden Sie diesen selektiven Aspekt nicht umgehen können bei der Anwendung der Keimbahntherapie.
Zumindest bei der Anwendung an Embryonen.
Das ist jetzt natürlich die Perspektive auf die vererbbaren Eigenschaften, also diese Keimbahn.
Man kann sich doch aber auch vorstellen, dass man genauso auch gezielt Krankheiten angeht.
Also etwas, was sich sozusagen in den nicht vererbbaren Zellen durchgesetzt hat.
Mir würde jetzt mal so Krebs einfallen, so als universelles Übel, wo es ja für viele Formen noch nicht mal den Ansatz einer Therapie zu geben scheint.
Ist das vorstellbar, dass die Technologie an der Stelle auch wirken kann?
Das ist vorstellbar und es gibt auch eine ganze Reihe von Studien, die momentan daran arbeiten und ähnlich wie bei der Keimbahntherapie kann man dabei von einem internationalen Wettrennen sprechen.
Also gerade um die 2015/16er Jahre herum, als CRISPR breit gehypt wurde als neue Wunderwaffe gegen alles,
überschlugen sich die Nachrichten, ob es das chinesische Team ist oder das US-amerikanische Team ist, was zuerst in die klinische Studie hineinführt.
Solche Genscherentherapien.
Das Ganze ist natürlich forschungsethisch bedenklich, wenn man merkt, das Ganze ist eher getrieben von Publicity als von einer wirklichen Sicherheit eines entsprechenden Verfahrens.
Aber um nochmal auf die Frage zurückzukommen, es gibt momentan eine ganze Reihe von Versuchen mit diesen Genscheren,
dass man Erbkrankheiten häufig, aber eben auch Krebs versucht zu behandeln.
Es gab jetzt vor zwei oder drei Wochen grünes Licht für erste Experimente in Deutschland mit diesen Genscheren.
Und wie gesagt, das sind immer dann Formen einer somatischen Gentherapie, von der man diese Keimbahntherapie unterscheiden muss.
Weil diese somatischen Gentherapien, die sind eben nicht erblich.
Also somatisch ist sozusagen alles, was nicht Erbzellen sind.
Genau, das sind …
??? des Körpers.
Das sind die Körperzellen, das ist die Veränderung der Körperzellen von einem Patienten im Vergleich zu diesen Keimbahnzellen, die vererbbar sind.
Und damit verbinden sich momentan eine ganze Reihe von Hoffnungen, dass daraus neue therapeutische Entwicklungen heraussprießen könnten sozusagen.
Zugleich, wie vorhin schon einschränkend gesagt, wir haben solche Gentherapien schon seit den frühen 90er Jahren,
ohne dass sie bisher wirklich eine breite Anwendung gefunden haben oder auch ein spannendes Phänomen, was zu beobachten ist,
dass die Entwicklung von solchen Gentherapien mitunter so teuer waren, dass diese Gentherapien zum Teil auch auf den Markt gebraucht wurden,
allerdings vielleicht eine Million Euro für eine Einmaldosis gekostet haben, so dass es dafür keinen realen Markt gab, weil keine Versicherung das bezahlen wollte.
Und dann waren sie zwar entwickelt worden, aber wieder vom Markt genommen.
Und da muss man momentan aufpassen, da auch zu viel zu versprechen in Bezug auf das, was denn die Genomeditierung am Patienten einmal leisten kann.
Und zweitens muss man zugleich auch sagen, wir reden zwar alle von dieser vermeintlich präzisen Genomchirurgie, von dem Genskalpell, was da angesetzt wird,
ein großes Problem ist aber weiterhin, an den richtigen Ort zu kommen, um diese Genscheren wirken zu lassen.
Es ist bisher keineswegs risikolos möglich, diese Gentherapien zur Anwendung, diese neuen Genomeditierungen zur Anwendung zu bringen.
Und man muss ganz nüchtern auch sagen, wenn man in den letzten Monaten verfolgt, wie die Forschung aus den Laboren neue Hoffnungen, aber eben auch Risiken, streut,
dass wir nüchtern sagen müssen, wir haben da noch nicht sehr viel verstanden in Bezug auf das, was eigentlich die Chancen und Risiken von diesen CRISPR-Genscheren sind.
Um Ihnen 1-2 Beispiele zu geben, im letzten Jahr gab es eine vielbeachtete Studie, da hat man eine solche Genomeditierung an Mäusen vorgenommen
und merkte später, oh diese Mäuse, da hat es an ganz ganz vielen Stellen editiert, wo es nicht editieren sollte und da war CRISPR totgesagt für 1-2 Wochen.
Man merkte dann später, das kann nicht reproduziert werden diese Versuche.
Dieses Jahr merkte man, CRISPR war ja eigentlich auch so ein Abwehrmechanismus gegen Viren,
vielleicht könnten Patienten ja auch sozusagen einen Immunität oder Immunreaktion auf CRISPR auslösen.
Und es zeigte sich tatsächlich, manche Patienten können vermeintlich oder manche Gewebeproben können vermeintlich eine Immunreaktion auslösen, schon war CRISPR wieder tot.
Zwei Wochen später ist es wieder auferstanden.
Jetzt hat sich gezeigt, CRISPR scheint zu einer Aktivierung eines Enzyms zu führen, was uns in der Regel vor Krebs schützt.
Das heißt, es könnte sein, dass eine CRISPR-Genomeditierung selbst dazu führt, dass wir anfälliger sind für die Ausbildung von Krebs
und schon war wieder CRISPR totgesagt, zwei Wochen später ist es wieder auferstanden.
Ich erzähle diese Anekdoten nur, um zu sagen, da ist momentan wirklich sehr sehr viel auf und ab in der Community mit dabei
und gerade das, was in den Medien dann rausdringt aus den Laboren ist eine ständiger Untergang und Auferstehung dieser Genscheren.
Wiederum ich glaube, dahinter verbirgt sich momentan noch ein großes Fragezeichen, dass wir eben wirklich die Entwicklung nicht genau absehen können
und da auch mit einer gewissen Offenheit, aber auch Nüchternheit vielleicht drangehen sollten und schauen, was die zukünftigen Entwicklungen bringen,
aber da eben auch nicht versuchen, in dieses Wettrennen mit hineinzusteigen, weil soweit können wir sehen, da wird es keine Gewinner geben.
Wenn wir Anwendungen versuchen, vorzeitig in die Klinik zu bringen.
Und vielleicht noch als Hintergrund, die Entwicklung der Gentherapien, die es bisher gab, die wurden durch einen tragischen, man kann gar nicht sagen Unglücksfall,
weil es war auch medizinisches Versagen, wurde gestoppt, nämlich Ende der 90er Jahre mit dem bekannten Fall von Jesse Gelsinger.
Das war eine Person, ein 19-jähriger US-Amerikaner, an dem eine solche experimentelle Gentherapie durchgeführt wurde.
Er ist daraufhin gestorben, als Folgen dieser Gentherapie und er hatte keineswegs eine Erkrankung gehabt, die ihm sein Leben unmöglich gemacht hätte.
Er hätte im wesentlichen ein Leben lang Diät halten müssen und er war aber betroffen von dieser entsprechenden Krankheit, gegen die therapiert werden sollte.
Und da merkt man wieder, es ist eben nicht nur eine Wunderwaffe, es ist auch ein sehr sehr gefährliches Werkzeug.
Heute reden wir natürlich von anderen Ansätzen, aber im Prinzip sind sie weiterhin hochrisikoreich für Probanden und dementsprechend müssen sie auch behandelt und reglementiert werden.
Ja, ein Grund mehr, dass sich die Ethikforschung hier zu diesem Zeitpunkt auch schon gut mit einmischt.
Konkret, das hatten wir, glaube ich, noch gar nicht erwähnt, was die Ethik der Genomeditierung betrifft, gibt es ja genau hier auch eine extra Forschungsstelle,
die sich genau mit diesen Fragen beschäftigt.
Bezieht sich das, also jetzt hatten wir ja im Prinzip schon zwei Anwendungsbereiche, wo das überhaupt alles zutrifft,
nämlich auf der einen Seite die Pflanzenwelt, also im wesentlichen unsere Ernährungsfragen,
jetzt haben wir natürlich auch schon die Auswirkungen auf die menschliche Entwicklung debattiert.
Man könnte im Prinzip ja die Tierwelt jetzt auch noch mit reinnehmen, sind das alles so Fälle, die auch verfolgt werden?
Wir sind ja hier wie gesagt an der medizinischen Fakultät, das heißt, unser Augenmerk gilt der Anwendung am Menschen.
Man kann gerade auch aufgrund der Möglichkeiten, Grenzen zu überschreiten durch die Genomeditierung, weil wir haben ja da ein Werkzeug, was uns erlaubt,
an allen Lebewesen Veränderungen vorzunehmen, kann man nicht immer einschränken,
das Ganze ist jetzt eine klar humane Anwendung oder außerhumane Anwendung.
Aber unser Fokus gilt insbesondere den somatischen Gentherapien, also den Körperzellen- und den Keimbahntherapien
und darüber hinaus auch noch anderen gesundheitsbezogenen Anwendungsgebieten der Genomeditierung.
Was wir hier machen ist, dass wir seit 2017 mit der Forschungsstelle Ethik der Genomeditierung, die durch den deutschen Stifterverband gefördert wird, versuchen,
langfristig ethische, soziale und rechtliche Fragen, die sich aus der Entwicklung solcher Technologien ergeben, ethisch zu reflektieren,
aber auch in die Öffentlichkeit hinaus zu kommunizieren.
Und da sind wir jetzt seit etwa einem Jahr dabei.
Um Ihnen ein Beispiel zu geben, jetzt gerade Mitte dieses Jahres haben wir ein Gutachten im Auftrag des Büros für Technikfolgeabschätzung beim deutschen Bundestag verfasst,
eben genau zu diesen Fragen der Keimbahntherapie, ob die in Deutschland zulässig sein darf oder nicht?
Momentan ist sie das nicht nach dem Embryonenschutzgesetz.
Da gibt es aber einige, die sagen, das müssen wir überarbeiten, weil wir auch solche Forschung an Embryonen erlauben wollen.
Dafür haben wir jetzt gerade ein Gutachten erarbeitet, wir sind recht rege dabei, mit öffentlichen Workshops,
auch Bürgerdialogen zu versuchen, eine breitere Diskussion anzustoßen über ethische Fragen der Genomeditierung
und daneben machen wir natürlich ganz klassische Grundlagenforschung in der Medizinethik, dass wir über die ethischen, rechtlichen Herausforderungen reflektieren,
die sich damit verbinden können mit solchen Entwicklungen.
Wie weit muss man denn jetzt diese ethische Frage noch denken?
Also ich hatte jetzt vorhin auch noch kurz so die Tierwelt erwähnt, um einfach auch die Auswirkungen davon noch ein bisschen breiter zu streuen.
Jetzt gibt es ja ohnehin diverse erhebliche Eingriffe in die Tierwelt, die wir ohnehin haben, allein dadurch, dass Lebensraum genommen wird,
durch die Verunreinigung der Welt, allein so die enorme Menge an Licht, die wir erzeugen, die sich ja negativ auf die Insekten auswirkt.
Das sind ja alles solche Fragen.
Jetzt ist das vielleicht für die Medizinethik nicht konkret, aber ich wollte mal, sagen wir mal mal, so generell diesen Ethikbegriff nochmal ein bisschen weiter fassen,
vielleicht in Bezug auf so eine Weltethik, wie gehen wir denn sozusagen überhaupt mit unserer Natur um.
Spielt das noch ein bisschen eine Rolle oder gibt es da vielleicht noch ein paar andere Gedanken in die Richtung?
Ja. Das spielt auf verschiedenen Ebenen eine Rolle.
Um Ihnen ein Beispiel zu geben, was vielleicht am greifbarsten ist und auch medizinbezogen,
das ist die sogenannte Anwendung der Gene Drives.
Gene Drives sind eine Art Werkzeuge, die auch erst durch die Genomeditierung möglich wurden,
die es erlauben, eine Art Vererbungsturbo in Organismen einzubringen.
Ich erzähle Ihnen, was das heißt.
Wir haben global gesehen eine große Krankheitslast durch Infektionskrankheiten.
Eine der häufigsten Infektionskrankheiten ist Malaria mit über 200 Millionen Malariafällen pro Jahr,
mit beinahe 50 Millionen Todesfällen pro Jahr als Folge von Malaria.
Und nun ist die Frage, können wir vielleicht diese neuen Möglichkeiten der Genetik, der Biologie nutzen,
um hier Ansätze zu entwickeln, die es erlauben, Malaria auszurotten als Krankheit, ähnlich wie wir es mit anderen Krankheiten in der Vergangenheit geschafft haben.
Und da gibt es einen sehr spannenden Ansatz und das ist dieser Gene Drive-Ansatz und der schaut,
was ist eigentlich die Ursache des Problems?
Die Ursache ist die Anopheles-Mücke, also eine Mücke, die Malaria überträgt.
Und nun ist die Idee so simpel wie bestechend, wenn wir diese Mücke loswerden könnten, könnten wir damit vielleicht auch die Krankheitslast von 200 Millionen Ansteckungen mit Malaria im Jahr loswerden
und der Krankheit quasi ein Schnippchen schlagen und das effektiver als durch bisherige Verfahren, nämlich Insektizide oder das Trockenlegen von Gebieten, wo diese Malaria-Mücke wohnt.
Und was man momentan versucht und das hat ganz überraschend gut funktioniert bisher in den Laboren,
ist, dass man beispielsweise männliche Anopheles-Mücken auf eine Art und Weise verändert, dass sie ein Gen vererben,
was die nächste Generation unfruchtbar macht, aber noch mehr, sie haben nun eben diesen sogenannten Vererbungsturbo mit eingebaut,
der dafür sorgt, dass dieses Gen sich ganz ganz kräftig ausbreitet in der Population und so haben Sie nach drei oder vier Generationen von Anopheles-Mücken dieses Gen bei allen Mücken.
Wodurch wird dieser Turbo ausgelöst?
Das ist an sich Vererbungslehre, die da ausgenutzt wird.
Wenn Sie sich an Ihre Schulzeit zurückerinnern, wenn Sie da immer so zwei Alele??? sehen bei einzelnen Organismen, dann ist die Frage,
ist da etwas dominant oder ist da etwas rezessiv, ist da etwas homozygot oder heterozygot?
Ist also, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sich das Gen weiter vererbt, wird quasi erhöht?
Genau, die Wahrscheinlichkeit wird erhöht und das führt dann eben dazu, dass Sie innerhalb von sehr kurzer Zeit eine Erbeigenschaft durch eine Population quasi vererben können.
Und wenn man das dann in den Freifeldversuch bringen würde, so die Theorie, könnte man es schaffen, dass die Anopheles-Mücke unfruchtbar wird.
Und dann dauert es nicht lange und die Anopheles-Mücken-Population wäre ausgestorben.
Aber wie kann denn jetzt sozusagen, wenn sich die weiter fortpflanzende Eigenschaft ist, dass es nicht mehr fruchtbar ist,
wie soll es denn dann einen Turbo auslösen, also es müsste doch eigentlich schon im ersten Schritt in sich selber zusammenfallen.
Sie werden wahrscheinlich in der ersten Generation von Mücken noch fruchtbare Mücken haben.
In der zweiten Generation werden Sie dann vielleicht die Hälfte fruchtbar, die andere Hälfte unfruchtbar haben.
Und in der dritten Generation werden Sie vielleicht alle unfruchtbar haben und so können Sie – das ist jetzt wie gesagt statistische Theorie -
können Sie in der dritten Generation eine komplett unfruchtbare Population haben und die würde dann damit eben die letzte Population sein.
Also das wäre dann so eine Art Mückengenozid?
Das wäre eine Art, ja sozusagen, Genozid wäre vielleicht sogar ein unsensibles Wort in diesem Zusammenhang,
weil den Mücken wird ja in dem Sinne, sie werden nicht abgeschlachtet, sondern sie sterben einfach aus ???
??? Im Prinzip rottet man ja sozusagen dann die Mücke auch aus.
Man rottet die Mücke damit sozusagen aus, aber damit eben auch den Überträger von Malaria.
Und das Ganze, diese Idee von Gene Drives, die ist mittlerweile schon etwa 15 Jahre alt, aber jetzt erst kürzlich hat man geschafft, durch CRISPR das eben so zu designen,
dass diese halbwegs zuverlässig funktionieren, halbwegs heißt, man hat es bisher hauptsächlich im Labor unter Laborbedingungen versucht,
weil es verbinden sich natürlich auch sehr sehr viele Gefahren, muss man sagen, mit einem Freifeldversuch,
weil so eine Anopheles-Mücke kann man eben nicht wieder zurückrufen, die fliegt dann natürlich rum.
Und man hat da zurecht Bedenken, was das mit einem Ökosystem machen könnte.
Um Ihnen ein Beispiel zu geben, 2015 hat man das erstmals mit verschiedenen Fliegenarten versucht, dass man diese zu Testzwecken gelblich gefärbt hat.
Man hat mit diesen Gene Drives es geschafft, dass die Population im Labor dann irgendwann diesen leicht geblichen Ton hatte
und man hat berechnet, dass innerhalb eines Jahres, wenn nur eine Mücke entkommen wäre aus dem Labor, etwa ein Fünftel der Mückenpopulation weltweit auch diese Gelbfärbung tragen könnte.
Das war eine Hochrechnung, ob das passiert wäre, man weiß es nicht.
Aber das deutet nur an, was da die Sicherheitsrisiken sind.
Aus diesem Grund wurde diese Gene Drive-Technologie bzw. CRISPR auch von hohen Offiziellen der Sicherheitsdienste in US-Amerika als eine Massenvernichtungswaffe gerechnet.
Weil man könnte sich ja auch vorstellen, was könnte so ein Gene Drive machen, wenn sie ihn nutzen, um einen möglichst tödlichen Bazillus zu entwickeln.
Das Ganze ist momentan Science Fiction, aber eben nicht nur, weil technisch gesehen könnte das möglich sein,
und dementsprechend sind da Informationssicherheitsdienste da hinterher, das Ganze auch zu überwachen,
auch mit zu finanzieren, dagegen zu entwickeln.
Aber zurück zu der Frage von Ihnen, mit solchen Gene Drives ist es möglich, dass Sie in gesamte Ökosysteme eingreifen
und damit eine Art zum Aussterben bringen.
Spannenderweise geht auch genau das Gegenteil mit CRISPR.
Da es eine ganze Reihe von Forschungsprojekten, die eben nicht nur Arten aussterben lassen wollen, sondern die Arten wiederbeleben wollen.
Um Ihnen ein Beispiel zu geben, Anfang des Jahres ging die Nachricht rum, dass dieses Breitmaulnashorn, der letzte Bulle, gestorben ist,
das heißt, wir haben jetzt gerade, ich glaube, noch zwei Weibchen weltweit, die Population wird damit aussterben, weil es gibt eben keine Nachkommen.
Die Überlegung ist nun, naja wir haben ja normale Nashörner und wenn man jetzt normale Nashörner mit Genomediting so verändern könnte,
dass sie im wesentlichen geboren werden als Breitmaulnashorn, könnte man die bestehenden Kälber damit eben zu einer weiteren Familienplanung von Breitmaulnashörnern motivieren,
weil man hätte wieder Spendersamen.
Ähnlich funktioniert es mit einem groß angelegten Projekt, was für sich beansprucht, das Mammut wieder zu beleben.
Und da gibt es Crowdfunding-Kampagnen, eine ganz Reihe, die sagen, ja wir haben genügend eingefrorene Mammuts irgendwo gefunden,
wir kommen an die Erbanlagen, an die DNA, von Mammuts ran, jetzt geht es nur noch darum, dass wir entsprechend Elefantenembryonen auf eine Art und Weise verändert müssten
und dann könnten wir einen Jurassic Park wiederbeleben.
Der ist im Übrigen auch schon angemietet, nämlich in Russland.
Hat auch noch einen sehr spannenden Nebeneffekt, zumindest die Macher von diesem Pleistozän-Park, wie er sich nennt, die erhoffen sich durch die Mammuts,
dass diese die Permafrostböden verdichten könnten und so zugleich noch einen Vorteil für den Klimaschutz.
Indem die da einfach rumstampfen.
Genau, indem die da rumstampfen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das Ganze einer wissenschaftlichen Prüfung standhalten könnte.
Oh man.
Aber so wird es zumindest mit beworben.
Und tatsächlich, es gibt auch mittlerweile eine eigene Agentur in US-Amerika, die sich um die Wiederauferstehung von ausgestorbenen Arten bemüht.
Und das sind dann in der Regel Arten, die eben durch menschliches Zutun ausgestorben sind.
Ein anderes Beispiel ist die Wandertaube oder auch der Pyrenäensteinbock, die sind mittlerweile ausgestorben,
weil sie im Fall der Wandertaube exzessiv bejagt wurden, etwa vor 100 Jahre.
Man versucht jetzt, durch die Veränderung von Tauben eben diese Wandertauben wiederzubeleben.
oder der Pyrenäensteinbock wurde bereits in den 2000ern, ich glaube, 2003 oder 2004 wurde er bereits schon einmal geklont,
ist wieder auferstanden, ist wieder ausgestorben, weil der Klon nicht überlebt hat.
Da haben Sie quasi ein Tier, was zweimal ausgestorben ist, das ist auch eine Premiere.
In gewisser Weise traurig, aber Sie sehen, in welche Richtung das geht.
Das ist eben die Vorstellung von einer sehr ausgeprägten Naturgestaltung und auch eine Form von – man würde es wahrscheinlich auf englisch – Solutionism??? nennen.
Dass wir Technologien einsetzen, um Probleme zu lösen, die wir durch Technologien hervorgerufen haben.
Und gerade wenn es dann eben darum geht, dass wir sehr sehr invasiv in Ökosysteme eingreifen,
sei es, indem wir Arten ausrotten und da ist die Anopheles-Mücke nicht die einzige, es geht auch ums Ausrotten von beispielsweise Nagetieren auf Inselpopulationen???,
die wir einmal eingeschleppt haben und die für lokale Vögel eine Bedrohung sind, da gibt es auch entsprechende Versuche,
dass wir hier gesamte Populationen ausrotten oder neue Arten erschaffen,
müssen wir natürlich zugestehen, dass wir da sehr sehr wenig wissen können momentan, was das mit einem Ökosystem macht.
Und da sehe ich auch weiterhin auf der Forschungsebene einen ausgeprägten Reflexionsbedarf, aber eben auch auf der Ebene der – nennen wir es ganz platt – Bürgerbeteiligung.
Weil wenn es darum geht, dass solche Anopheles-Mücken irgendwo in Zentralafrika ausgesetzt werden, haben dann natürlich auch Menschen vor Ort ein Wörtchen mitzureden.
Und da müssen sich ausgeprägtere Bemühungen zeigen als momentan, dass man da versucht, offene Bürgerdialoge über derartige Fragen auch zu finden.
Und die natürlich nicht eingeschränkt sein können auf einzelne Regionen, weil wir das Ganze per Definition nicht auf eine Stadt begrenzen können.
Vielleicht zum Schluss nochmal der Blick auf so die menschliche Entwicklung, diese ganze Gentechnik ist ja nicht nur mit den Möglichkeiten der Modifikation und Selektion ganz interessant geworden.
Es gibt ja jetzt mittlerweile auch größere Unternehmen, die durch Genanalyse auch schon bestimmte Dinge meinen, aus dem eigenen Genomvorrat Sachen herauslesen zu können,
da stellt sich ja schon auch mal die Frage, will man das überhaupt wissen?
Also möchte ich überhaupt wissen, dass ich nur noch so und so lange zu leben habe?
Möchte ich wissen, welche Krankheiten ich theoretisch bekommen könnte, auch wenn ich sie vielleicht nicht bekomme?
Aber da scheint sich ja schon ein ziemlich großer Markt entwickelt zu haben, der ganz interessante Blüten treibt.
Ist das auch etwas, was so die Ethik im Blick hat?
Auf jeden Fall, also gerade der gesamte Bereich der Gendiagnostik ist etwas, wo wir momentan zahlreiche Entwicklungen sehen,
die alle mit sehr vielen ethischen Fragen verbunden sind, die wir hier auch reflektieren.
Um Ihnen ein Beispiel zu geben, seit der sogenannten Entschlüsselung des menschlichen Genoms, also durch das Humangenomprojects zwischen 1990 und 2003,
können wir sagen, okay, das menschliche Genom ist so und so aufgebaut.
Das ist aber nicht mal die halbe Miete.
Tatsächlich müssten wir wissen, welche einzelnen Genabschnitte korrelieren mit verschiedenen Phänotypen, also Ausprägungen mit Eigenschaften, die wir haben,
sei es gesundheitsbezogener Natur oder nicht.
Und da hat man in den letzten Jahren doch eine ganze Reihe von Fortschritten zu verzeichnen, dass man über die Sequenzierung des menschlichen Genoms zunehmend meint,
Aussagen treffen zu können über einzelne Mutationen, die mit Krankheiten, mit Krankheitsrisiken,
aber vielleicht auch mit nicht krankheitsbezogenen menschlichen Eigenschaften in Verbindung stehen.
In Ländern, in denen das Ganze sehr lax reguliert ist, wie zum Beispiel den Vereinigten Staaten, finden Sie nun einen sehr ausgeprägten Markt von Anbietern,
die potentiellen, ich möchte sie nicht mal Patienten, sondern eher Kunden nennen, Kunden es ermöglichen, privat ihr Genom sequenziellen zu lassen.
Das Ganze kann ich von zu Hause aus machen.
Ich bestelle mir dann ein kleines Röhrchen, in das spucke ich rein, schicke das zurück an ein Labor, dann wird das sequenziert
und dann bekomme ich ausgewertet auf mein Smartphone oder auf einer Internetplattform nicht nur, wo vielleicht meine Wurzeln her sind,
also genetisch gesehen wo ich herkomme, sondern eben auch, was für Krankheitsrisiken ich in mir trage,
dass ich einmal an diesen oder jenen Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen erkranken könnte,
aber auch und das ist der Bogen zurück zur Reproduktion, was ich denn für ein genetisches „Potenzial“ haben könnte, Nachkommen zu zeugen.
Und hier finden Sie mittlerweile zum Beispiel Apps auf dem Markt, also wirklich für Ihr Smartphone, die erlauben es Ihnen,
dann gemeinsam mit Ihrem Partner einen solchen Test durchzuführen und dann kriegen Sie vorgerechnet,
ja, Sie haben eine so und so hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit, ein gesundes Kind zu bekommen.
Sie haben eine Wahrscheinlichkeit, die so und so hoch ist, dass Ihr Kind diese oder jene Hautfarbe, diese oder jene Augenfarbe haben wird und so weiter.
Und da sehen wir gerade eine sehr zunehmende, könnte man sage, Genetisierung von Lebensphänomenen im Bereich auf die Fortpflanzung,
die sich aber eben auch bei den Individuen sehr sehr weit auswirken könnten auf Fragen der Lebensführung.
Weil natürlich macht das etwas mit einem, wenn sie statistisch hübsch aufbereitet, das sieht dann meist grafisch sehr schön aus, sehen,
Sie haben ein so und so viel erhöhtes Risiko, dass Sie einmal an Prostatakrebs erkranken könnten.
Da ist dann zum einen die Frage für viele, was machen sie mit diesen Informationen, weil wir alle haben ein sehr hohes Risiko, einmal zu sterben, das ist schon mal gesetzt.
Die Frage ist dann eher, okay was sind jetzt die möglichen absoluten oder relativen Risiken, die bei mir erhöht sind?
Möchte ich das überhaupt wissen?
Erfahre ich da vielleicht was, was nicht nur mich selbst betrifft, sondern auch noch meine Anverwandten betrifft,
weil es kann ja natürlich sein, dass die Mutation, die ich trage, auch meine Schwester tragen könnte und so weiter.
Und was hat das Ganze dann für einen Einfluss auf meine Lebensplanung?
Das vielleicht flagranteste Beispiel, was auch medial sehr breit verhandelt wurde, war der Gentest, den Angelina Jolie hat machen lassen bei sich,
bevor sie sich zu der Entfernung ihrer Brüste entschieden hat.
Weil sie hat eine Mutation getragen, die ist bekannt dafür, dass sie mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit zu Brustkrebs oder Gebärmutterhalskrebs führen kann
und sie hat daraus die Konsequenz geschlossen, sie möchte gern dieses Risiko selbst für auf diese Art und Weise gemanagt haben.
Das ist aber nur eine mögliche Geschichte, die man erzählen könnte, es gibt auch andere Arten und Weisen mit einem solchen Risiko umzugehen,
es hat aber zugleich für viele suggeriert, es ist für mich als Person das einzig richtige, verantwortungsbewusst über meine Gene so viel wie möglich zu erfahren
und dann daraus eine Konsequenz zu ziehen, die möglichst risikominimierend ist.
Aber das wie gesagt ist eine Frage, die berührt noch ganz andere Bereiche, außer diese sehr direkte Entscheidung, die da getroffen wurde.
Und ich glaube, hier gibt es auch für die Ethik sehr viel zu tun, was da diese Konsequenzen auf einer gesellschaftlichen Ebene von diesem Genomsequenzierungsverfahren ausmacht.
Ich meine, das ist wirklich schwierig zu entscheiden.
Ich wundere mich jetzt auch gerade über diese Konsequenz der Entscheidung, man hätte ja auch genauso gut sagen können,
naja, wenn ich da ein hohes Risiko habe, dann beobachte ich das halt einfach etwas intensiver und dann weiß ich ja vielleicht woran ich bin.
Genau, das wäre eine der möglichen Strategien gewesen.
Was wir momentan sehen können, auch mit Blick auf die Firmen, die das anbieten, ist einfach, dass sie mit einer trügerischen Sicherheit versuchen,
einen Markt für sich zu erobern, dass die Werbeclips, die beispielsweise geschaltet sind, das ist gar nicht so wenig in den entsprechenden Ländern, wo die zugelassen sind,
eben suggerieren für Personen, es ist für mich in meinem eigenen Interesse, das allerbeste selbstverantwortlich für meine Genetik zu sein,
das heißt, ich muss möglichst viel wissen.
Und dieses möglichst viel wissen ist eben nur ein Konzept, was man auch neben anderen Konzepten haben kann, wie man mit seinen möglichen Lebensrisiken umgeht.
Hinzu kommt, dass sehr viel von dem, was da auf den Markt geworfen wird momentan, eher keiner wissenschaftlichen Prüfung standhalten würde, muss man sagen.
Weil häufig gar nicht klar ist, wie kommt man eigentlich zu diesen Einsichten über, da ist jetzt ein genetisches Risiko oder vielleicht auch ein genetisches Potenzial da.
Um Ihnen ein Beispiel zu nennen, es gibt seit einer ganzen Weile schon Tests, die meinen, vorhersagen zu können,
wie meine Intelligenz sich ausprägt im Vergleich zu anderen Personen in meiner Kohorte.
Das Ganze könnte theoretisch auch auf Embryonen angewandt werden, es gibt Neugeborenen-Screenings,
die können bis zu 500 Faktoren erfassen, alleine fünf Faktoren für die Entwicklung von Haaren,
also etwa Glatzenbildung, Haarfarbe, Haardicke, Lockigkeit und so weiter und da werden einfach extrem viele Informationen generiert,
die eine trügerische Machbarkeit suggerieren, nämlich als könnten wir 1:1 vorhersehen, was denn die Genetik mit uns macht.
Und das ist eine Form von Determinismus, der nicht nur wissenschaftlich falsch ist, sondern der auch gefährlich sein kann.
Weil indem wir suggerieren, dass wir so einen Einfluss, so eine Steuerbarkeit von Genetik, von unsren Erbanlagen hinbekommen können,
schaffen wir zugleich auch Verantwortungsräume.
Weil dann bin ich auf einmal dafür verantwortlich, wenn ich eben nicht interveniere, obwohl ich weiß, dass ich doch dieses oder jenes hätte.
Analog dazu könnten wir fragen, wenn heute Eltern ihren neugeborenen Kindern zum Beispiel eine Bluttransfusion verweigern würden,
wenn sie eine Bluttransfusion brauchen, weil die Eltern zum Beispiel Zeugen Jehovas sind,
kann das Ganze ein Fall sein für die Staatsanwaltschaft.
Warum nicht auch sagen in der Zukunft zu Eltern, von denen wir wissen, ihr habt schlechte Gene,
wenn ihr euch fortpflanzt, wollen wir das auch nicht als Gesellschaft.
Das wäre ein analoger Fall, dass wir auf einmal von dieser Vorstellung von genetischer Machbarkeit, neue Verantwortungsräume kreieren,
das setzt sich natürlich auch fort bei Fragen des Versicherungsschutzes, wieviel muss ich eigentlich für meine Versicherung bezahlen,
wenn ich doch eigentlich weiß, dass ich dieses und jenes Risiko habe, aber nicht so oder so präventiv dagegenwirke.
Und dieses Schaffen von neuen Verantwortungsräumen oder vermeintlichen Verantwortungsräumen ist, glaube ich, eins der großen Gefahren, die sich damit verbinden,
mit so einer Genetisierung von Lebensphänomenen.
Wirkt sich ja auch auf die Kriminalistik aus.
Es gibt ja in letzter Zeit auch, ich glaube, in Holland ist das verbreitet, dass man eben auch Spuren von Tatorten,
wo ja dann auch schon so Genproben genommen werden und bestimmte Schlüsse daraus gezogen werden
einerseits natürlich dieses, war Person X der oder die Täterin?
Dass man eben auf Basis dieser genetischen Auswertung halt auch Fahndungen macht und dann zum Beispiel nach Herkunftsländern auch sozusagen Wahrscheinlichkeiten bildet.
Wie wahrscheinlich ist es, dass diese Person von dort und dort hierher migriert ist oder hier vielleicht geboren wurde?
Was Sie ja auch sehr spannendes haben, ist, dass Sie natürlich wissen müssen, wenn Sie Ihre genetischen Daten abgeben,
weiß man natürlich nicht etwas über Sie, man weiß auch etwas über Ihre Eltern, man weiß etwas über Ihre Geschwister,
über Ihre Cousins und Cousinen.
Kinder.
Das Ganze hat verschiedene Konsequenzen.
Zum einen, bei entsprechenden Anbietern, die versuchen, Menschen zusammenzubringen, die genetisch verwandt sind,
das ist so eine Art Facebook auf Grundlage der DNA, dann kommt es immer wieder vor, dass man merkt,
ach der Onkel Harry, der hat ja da nicht nur diese und jene Kinder gehabt, da gibt es ja noch mehr, von denen wussten wir noch gar nichts.
Das ist ein übliches Phänomen, was sich in diesem Zusammenhang zeigt.
Aber eben auch, dass Sie indirekt auf das genetische Profil von unbekannten Personen schließen können
und das wurde in den letzten Monaten in verschiedenen Fällen auch genutzt, um Täter zu identifizieren.
Dass man wusste, wir suchen gerade eine Person, wir wissen aber nicht, wo wir sie finden können
und dann kann man eben über diese Datenbanken, wenn man darauf Zugriff hat und eine möglichst große Datenmenge hat,
kann man indirekt zumindest rausfinden, okay seine Schwester haben wir hier gefunden
und hier könnte dieser oder jener Täter eben auch zu finden sein
und das ist eine sehr spannende Verzahnung, momentan von BigData und Genetik kann man sehr sehr viel auch über Menschen erfahren,
die niemals ihre Daten abgegeben haben für solche Datenbanken.
Puh, das hat ja auch dystopisches Potenzial.
Das Ganze hat auch dystopisches Potenzial, bis hin zu Ländern, wo momentan erwogen wird, dass es verpflichtend sein kann für die Bevölkerung,
dass sie eben einen genetischen Fingerabdruck hinterlassen, dass man eben die gesamte Bevölkerung sequenzieren möchte.
Das Ganze kann mit Vorteilen gerade auch in der klinischen Forschung verbunden sein,
wenn wir eine große Datenbank haben, können wir sehen, wie sich beispielsweise einzelne …
Krankheiten verbreiten und so.
… Krankheiten verbreiten.
Es hat natürlich aber auch ein extremes Überwachungspotenzial, was Sie mit der Zentralisierung von allen Daten haben.
Puh. Die Zukunft wird irgendwie nicht weniger komplex.
Nicht weniger komplex, das stimmt.
Aber sie hält auch viel spannendes bereit.
Aber es ist wie immer eigentlich auch ein Abwägen von Chancen und Risiken.
Das ist ja etwas, was technologische Entwicklung eigentlich auf allen Ebenen immer wieder begleitet,
dass man merkt, okay, wir haben jetzt wieder mehr Möglichkeiten, es entstehen halt neue Risiken
und es entstehen aber halt auch neue Chancen.
Ich denke, das ist so ein bisschen der Ort, wo genau die Ethik an sich und ich weiß nicht, der Begriff Medizinethik, das ist jetzt hier im Fokus,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob der Begriff Ethik an sich ausreichend beschreibt, was man quasi gesamtgesellschaftlich an dieser Stelle
debattieren oder installieren sollte.
Ich weiß nicht, Technikethik oder so was, kann man so was so benennen?
Kann man sagen, ja.
Scheint mir durchaus eine Disziplin zu sein, auf die man noch mehr Fokus legen sollte.
Auf jeden Fall.
Und ich denke, das passiert auch in den letzten Jahren ziemlich ausgeprägt und das muss jetzt auch nicht unter dem Stichwort der Ethik laufen.
Das kann auch die Technikfolgenabschätzung sein.
Letztendlich verbindet diese Fragen das ganz grundsätzliche Interesse, wir wollen wissen,
was ist gut und was ist richtig und was wollen wir eigentlich als Gesellschaft gemeinsam haben?
Und da sind Technologien nun einmal wie sie sind, nämlich erst einmal für sich genommen neutral,
aber sie können auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise genutzt werden.
Und da müssen wir uns als Gesellschaft entscheiden, wo wollen wir Weichen stellen?
Und ich glaube, das, was wir gerade in Bezug auf die Genomeditierung oder auch die Veränderung von Nutzpflanzen sehen,
ist etwas, das reproduziert eine ganze Reihe von Herausforderungen, die kennen wir aus anderen Bereichen,
die aber gar nicht in der Technik als solche liegen.
Und hierzu kann zum Beispiel die Tendenz einer Kommerzialisierung gehören,
dass viele Menschen tatsächlich ein größeres Problem haben mit der Kommerzialisierung von Saatgut als mit der genetischen Veränderung.
Das ist einer der Gründe, weshalb der Monsanto ehemals so häufig in der Kritik stand als Inbegriff des Bösen für viele galt.
Weniger die grüne Gentechnik war es vermutlich.
Ähnlich mit der Datensammelwut von Institutionen, dass viele vielleicht gar kein Problem damit haben zu sagen,
eine Genomsequenzierung durchführen zu lassen, aber dass solche Daten zentralisiert irgendwo gespeichert werden
und gegebenenfalls dann für andere Institutionen oder nicht mehr transparent abrufbar sein könnten.
Und ich denke, da gibt es eine sehr spannende Überschneidung auch von verschiedenen Themenbereichen aus der Technologieentwicklung,
wo die Ethik aber eben auch angrenzende Disziplinen einiges an Arbeit zu leisten hat.
Aber eben immer in dem Versuch, auf Augenhöhe mit der Gesellschaft an diese Fragen ranzugehen.
Weil wie gesagt, es gibt keine Moralexperten im Bereich der Ethik.
Ja, ich sage mal, vielen Dank für diesen umfangreichen Blick auf Ethik und Genetik und was das alles noch so als Folge mit sich bringt, Herr Ranisch.
Vielen Dank.
Und damit enden wir hier diesen Diskurs und machen bald mit einem neuen Diskurs weiter.
Ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.